안녕하십니까, 재미턴 여러분. 행복한
투자 예정을 함께하는 체슬리 모닝
브리프 7월 15일 수요일 1부
시작하겠습니다.
아, 전위에 어떻게 맞췄는지 우선
중국시장 왕정부장님과 함께 먼저
보겠습니다.
>> 네. 어쨌는 저가 매수 자금 유입부
상의
했습니다. 어제보다는데 설자
줄렀어요. 업종별 좀 부시면 어제
소재 커뮤니케이션 IT 업인 강세
보였고 반면는 금융 피소비제 부동차의
업종이 약세되었습니다.
원자재 가급 반등 그리고 2번기 실적
기대감으로 소재 관련주 어제
급등했어요. 자금은 요퍼으로 하고요.
충구 아루미 9% 건리 9% 소프
8% 올라왔습니다. 구제 요가 성산에
따라서 에너지 관련주 어제도 강세를
보였고요. 배터너는 3.5% 신도팬는
3% 홍리석화는 4.4% 나왔어요.
어 이번에 허실적 기대감으로 권통신
관련주 좀 강세가 보였습니다. 종재
우청은 7% 신역승 11% 충북
관동신 5.5% 장비 관선는 4층
8% 우라고요. 어제 장 끝났고 장비
광 실적 발표했습니다. 실전 되게
좋게 나오고요. 아마 오늘은 그 그냥
쌍한 갈 가능성도 있습니다.음
이분기 실적 호쪽 그리고 저가 매수
자금으로 PCB 번 정도 돈
반등했습니다.
성인테크는 아래 부분에도 있어요.
인테크는 어제 10% 상한 갖기로
하고요. 동생 처밀 10% 허전 주시
10% 3% 정전 9% 올라왔습니다.
결론 반도체 업체주가 돈반 반등에
따라서 반도체 권령주도 상승했습니다.
한국기는 1.5%랑 테크는 6.8%
조이테크 6% 보방 화천는 1.3%
원하어요. 2차 청지 관련주도
반등했습니다. CT는 1.4% 이보
에너지도 1% 가격이 상천했어요.
반면은 어쨌든 금융 관영 방어주들이
다수 하라했습니다. 어 신염물 구체
금리 어제 0.5bp 5b
하였습니다. 구하면 염증 1b 선하고
확률이 염증 13% 잘성되었습니다.
>> 감사합니다. 우선 어 저희가 제
기억이 맞다면
>> 네
>> 어 증시 거래 대금이 한 3조 정도
넘었을 때 어 거래량이 좀 된다.
우리 이렇게 얘기하기로 얘기했던 거
같아요. 그보다는 좀 이제 못
미치니까맞아
>> 지수가 [콧방귀]
>> 상승을 많이 했음에도 불구하고
거래량이 좀 쫓아오진 않았다는 거는
아직은 [콧방귀] 조금 더 확인하고
싶다. 이렇게 이해해도 될까요?
>> 네. 그렇게 하시면 됩니다.
>> 네. 어제 지수가 비교적 중국 지수
치고는 변동폭이 좀 상승폭이 컸던 거
같습니다. 상해 지수 1.3, 선전
2.7, CSI 2.1, 창업은
3.4 뭐 이렇게 되니까
>> 어 중국 지수는 웬만해서 1% 이상
어 등락이 좀 없는데 최근엔 좀
있었던 거 같고 좀 전에 우리 오늘
상한가 갈 거라고 예상해 준 종목
이름이 뭐였죠?
>> 아 장비 광삼 광삼유 만든 회사고요.
>> 네. 장비 광섬은 실적이 어느 정도
나오면 그렇게 바로 예측이 됩니까?
어 우리 예선보다는 거의 많이 성후에
50% 이상해였습니다. 그래서 왜냐면
최근에 이런 회사 주가들이 거의 거전
대비 60% 정도 빠졌어요.
>> 뭐 단기적으로 상한가 가능성 뭐
>> 10% 정도 올라갈 수 있고 전비
권사는 주 거의 10% 상한가
기준으로 있어요. 홍콩는 그 상황과
기준 없어요. 그래서 대충 아마 전비
권사하면 홍콩 거의 30% 가까이
>> 몰아갈 수 가능성이 있어요.
>> 네. 내일 업데이트 한번 해 주세요.
>> 아, 네. 알겠습니다. [웃음]
>> 밑에 보니까 그 저 창신 메모리 공목
걱정이 된 모양입니다.
>> 한 주당 가격은 8.66이고맞
>> 모집 자금은 어 597억 위안에서
666억 위안이니까 한화로 따지면
13에서 15조원 정도.
>> 맞습니다.
>> 네. 그러면
>> 어 초기 밸류 그러니까요 밸류가
128조원
수준이라는 거는 공모가 8.66한
기준으로 말씀해 주신 거 같은데
>> 네. 그러면 어 128조 위안 중에
원화 기준 아 8조 128조
>> 원왕화 완화 기준
>> 원화 기준이죠
13에서 15조원 정도가 공목가니까
전체 발행 주식수에 뭐 10몇 %
정도밖에 안 되는 거네
>> 그냥 뭐 기하면은 10% 생각하시면
되고요. 뭐 초과 발행하면은 거의
12포 정도 그렇게 생각하시면 되고이
모지 자급는 대초는 597로 외한
정도 나왔습니다. 취하다는
기준 하면은 그래서 초기 그 무지
금액 대비는 두 배 정도 급정
증가했어요. 우리 그 예상대로는 가슴
수준 나왔습니다. 네네. 근데
문제가음이 [콧방귀]
어제는 어 이거 장기적으로 보유하는
사람 있잖아요. 전열적 투자자 그쪽은
다 락업고요. 거기서 1년 2년 정도
락업 가렸어요.
>> 어제 받은 리스트 좀 받는데
>> 안에서 보면 거의 다 뭐 중국 고민
연금
>> 그리고 연기금 이런 거 되 거의 다
되는 기관이고요.
>> 어 뭐 해외 기관은 하나도 없어요.
음. 네. 다 반도체 에티 관영주
그리고 [목을 가다듬음] 아리바
>> 그리고 랑기테크 이런 회사이고요.
아.
>> 네. 이미 다 내정되었는 느낌이
있습니다.
>> 음. 그러면 중국의 어떤 어 국가
기관 또는 어 중국의 큰 대형 기업들
뭐 이런 데들이
>> 결국은 90% 가까운 지분이
>> 중국 내 소유로 이제 시작이 되게
되는 거네요.
>> 음.
>> 그래서이 요통 주시수 그렇게 많지
[목을 가다듬음] 않다고
생각하습니다.
>> 네.
중국 어 CATM 그 창신 메모리 어
예상 시총
>> 네
>> 어느 정도로 예상
>> 아 저는 아직도 이거는 뭐 아니면
상정은 상관 없잖아요.
>> 우정 이런 회사는 1,000원은 거의
300% 이상 올라갈 수 있어요.
다만이 회사 시가 좀 크니까 면적
되고어요
>> 주의수 그렇게 많지 않고요. 뭐 5%
요밖에 없어요.
>> 근데 지금이 빨리로 역산하면은
네배예요. 음
>> 원래 기준으로 실전으로 예상하면
네배예요. 트위 버수적으로 맞아요.
버수적으로 얘기하면 뭐 거의 세배
네배 정도밖에 없어요.
>> 후 금융주 있잖아요. 뭐 공산 그
건설 있잖아요. 그 피어는 거의 열배
정도 돼요. 음. 좀 말이 안 되는
달리예요. 지금 뭐 해외로 보면은
뭐가 아니 정자 마이크로니 비교하면은
되게 뭐 비비 비비한 수준 생각할 수
있지만 충구 내에서는 프리미어
적응하는 시장이에요.
>> 그래서 입반력 받을 수 없다고 생각할
수 있습니다.
>> 음. 그러네요. 한국에 지금 하이닉스
삼성전자 이런 것들이 뭐 어떤 실적
기준으로 어떤 [목을 가다듬음]
어 연도 그 밸류에이션이에 따라
다르지만 뭐 여섯 배 일곱 배 뭐요
정도 수준이라고 보면
>> 어 128조원이 네배다 그러면
>> 어 중국 내시장 그리고 장기적으로
중국 내 생태에서 지위가 계속 올라갈
걸 생각하면
>> 뭐 한 그래도 최소한 하이닉스
삼성전자보다 좀 비싸져야 되는 거
아니야라고 생각하면
>> 뭐 50% 정도 오르면은 혹은
100% 정도 오르 오르면 되는 건데
중국내 대형 기업 생각하면 50%
100%가 아니라 200% 이상
올라야 되는 걸 수도 있고 그
어디에서 결정이 되지 않을까
싶습니다.
>> 네. 그래서 제가 밸런스 잡으면은
대충 5조 정도 5조 그러면 청조
정도 천조 정도 와 일부 여덟 배
>> 공목과 대비
>> 보겠습니다. 어 27일이라 그러셨던
거
>> 27일 성장입니다.네
>> 이번 달 안에 결정이 되니까 계속해서
업데이트
>> 부탁드리겠습니다네
생익테크 반복해서 업데이트 해 주시는
기업인데요. 들어보겠습니다.네
>> 어제는 상한가 기록하고요. 실전은
나왔습니다. 시가 초에는 80조원
되고 포드 PN는 49배 수준이고요.
글로벌 CCR 시장 MS 14%
이외를 유지하고 있고 매트코승로
보시면 CCR 67% PCB는 29%
정도면 됩니다. MB TP 300 종
15% 차지하고 있고요.
두산이잖아요. 두산 60% 70%
정도 이스만상 있고요. 5% 10%
수분입니다.
>> 음. 어 3반기 순위는 동의부터
131% 증가 예상입니다. 역산으로
하면은 이방대 순위는 그냥 동기대비
125%부터 148% 증가.
균는 67%부터 84% 증가하고요.
시장의 예상치 대비를 큰폭으로
상호했어요. 어 CCR 가격 인상
공장 가동률 상승의 PCB 매출
고승전동으로 허실적을 달성했습니다.
하반기 더 높은 성장세를 용지 가능성
좀 있고요. 7월 부단은이 홀산 이미
CCR 15% 정도 가격
인상했습니다. 거 부가지 CCR 출화
증가 ACB 교부 확대등 가능성도
있고요. 특히는 하반기 요리선 공부
공급 부조에 따라서 CCR 가격은
인상 지수 가능성이 있어요. 뭐 시장
예상대로는
내년까지는 계속 인상할 가능성이
있어요. 월별은 10% 15%씩
이렇게 돼 계속 유지할 수 있고 전선
증가 리퍼드 보면은 CCR 허공세
요지 거부가 CCR 출화 증가
등용으로 매수 위로 유지했어요.
올해부터 내년 내 홍연 순는 가카
80억 위한 122억 외한 185억
위한 추정되었고 지정 대비는 40%
44% 큰 불로 우상이었어요.
>> 음
>> 타켄 내년은 35배피아를 적용하면
TP는 175 정도는 가능성도
있어요.이 부분은 우리만 얘기했어요.
왜냐면 회사는 무효주가 세시하지
않았어요.
>> 그래서이 어제 종가 대비는 18%
없애 있습니다. 2년 EPS로
계산하면은 52% 나올 수 있고요.
그래서 현재 PG는 0.94배에
94배밖에 없어서 약간 미사지 않은
수준입니다.
>> 최근 산업 IT 산업 내 종목들이
이제 조정을 보이면서 오른쪽에
PERPBR 차트 보시면은 밴드를 확
뚫고 올라갔다가 살짝 조정을 보인
정도의 주가인데
>> 지난번 업데이트 해 주실 때도 제가
동일한 얘기 했던 거 같은데요. 어
가동률 상승하고 물량 늘어나고 그런데
그것보다 훨씬 더 높은이
추정치 이익 추정치 상향이 있다면
그럼 가격인 거 같은데
>> 가격이 이렇게 계속 올라갈 수 있는
건가 그런 얘기 드렸던 기억이 나요.
근데 여기 보면은
>> 어 추정 실적을 또 올렸어요.
>> 맞습니다.
>> 그럼 또 가격인가?네 네. 그런 거
같
>> 네. 좀 보겠습니다. 저희가 지금 어
가격 논리에 가격이 얼마 어디까지
올라갈 수 있는지에 대한 논리로 지금
삼성전자 하이닉스가 노이즈가 계속
나오고 있는데이 기업 같은 경우 그럼
지금 GPM이라고 해야 될까? 어
얼마 정도 될까요?
>> GPM이요?
>> 음
>> GPM 대충는
>> 여기도 뭐 80% 되고 그럴까? 아
80% 되는 상황은 아니고요.
아니에요. 아직 한참 남았어요.
>> 어 제가 그때 개산때는 대중에 40%
나오고 있었는데네 맞아요.
>> 40%
>> 이게 구조적으로 이제 CCL이라고
하는 부품 자체가 얼마의 GPM을
가질 수 있는지네
>> 어 완전가 그 CCR 이거 GP 높지
않아요. 높지 않지만 최근에 그냥
>> AI [콧방귀] 서버 들어가는 거 그
>> 전문 그 거층 MLB 들어가는 것이
제 알잖아요. 예전보다는 훨씬 더
가도 비싸졌어.
>> 음.
>> 그래서이 [목을 가다듬음] 부분 매출
비중 화대하면은 GP 마주는 40%
50% 이상 나올 수 있는 점이
있어요. 때문일 수도 있고 아니면
제품 자체가 고부가 제품으로 전환되는
부분도 있고 할 텐데 계속해서 어떤
이익의 모멘텀을 타고 있는 종목이다.
그렇게 이해를 좀 하고
넘어가겠습니다. 네.
>> 감사합니다. 중국 시장 봤고요. 전일
미국 시장 어땠는지 창민 프로와 함께
보겠습니다.
>> 네. 전일 미국 시장
말씀드리겠습니다. 전일 미국 정시는
6월 소비자 물가가 6년 만에
처음으로 하락하면서 그 7월 금리
인상 오려가 후퇴한 영향으로 좀
상승하는 전반적으로 상승하는 모습
보여줬습니다. 그 어닝 시즌 첫날
대양 운은행들의 호실적과 반도체
반등도 이에 힘을 좀 보이고요. 시장
전반을 살펴본 뒤 오늘은 파클레이스
커버리지 개시에 그 ADR 하이닉스
ADR이 27% 급등하며 본주와의
개율이 개리율이 50%에 욕박한음
>> 모습 보여준 부분에 대해서 좀 자세히
다뤄볼 예정이고요. 그리고 6년 만에
하락한 CPI와 연준 그리고 어닝
시즌에 문을 대원 운행들의 실적까지
정리해 될 예정입니다.
다음으로 미국 주요 지수 먼저
보겠습니다. SMP 500이
0.38% 38% 우리는
7,543포인트로 마감해서 하루 만에
반등하는 모습 보여줬고요.
>> 그리고 나스닥은 0.9%
그리고
러셀은 0.39% 그리고 다우가
0.02% 상승하는 모습
보여줬습니다. 그리고 필라델피아
반도체 지수가 2.54%
상승했는데요.
>> 음.
>> 어 주요 지수 가운데 상승폭이 좀
가장 큰 모습 보여주었고요. 그리고
다운은 0.02%밖에 02%밖에
상승하지 못한 이유는 편입 종목인M이
좀 부진했던 영향이 큰 것으로
보입니다. 다음으로 우측 SP 업종별
보시면 정보 기술이 1.3%
커뮤니케이션이 1.1% 상승하며 지수
상승을 좀 견인한 모습 보여주었고요.
그리고 에너지와 소재 금융도 소폭
상승했습니다. 반면에 헬스케어가
1.9% 필수 소비제가 1.4%
하락했고요. 유틸리티도 0.6% 6%
하락하는 모습 보여줬습니다. 전일
방어업정으로 좀 물렸던 모습
보여줬었는데 하루 만에 또 다시
성장주 위주로 돌아온 모습입니다.
다음으로 금리와 유가 보시겠습니다.
미국체 10년물 금리가 4v비P 내린
4.58% 기록했습니다. 6월
CPI가 전년 대비 3.5% 상승해
예상치 3.8%와 전월 4.2%를
모두 크게 믿돌았고요. 전월 대비로는
2020년 이후 6년 만에 처음으로
하락한 모습 보여줬습니다. 그리고
근원 CPI도 전년 대비 2.6%
6% 상승에서 예상치 2.8%와 전널
2.9%를 하여하였고 안정세를 확인해
줬습니다. 핑크라는 대형 치권
운영사가 이번 지표로 7월 인상은
사실상 논의에서 좀 빠졌다고
평가하면서 연준이 올해 내내 동결을
유지할 것이라는 기존 전망을
유지했습니다. 그래서 워시 연준
의장은의 증원에서 고물가를 용납하지
않겠다는 원칙을 좀 재확인해 주는
그런 모습 보여줬지만 특정 정책
경로를 약속하지는 않는 모습
보여줬고요. WTI는 2.1% 1%
올른 79.8달러로 8달러로 상승세를
이어갔습니다. 그렇지만 전일보다 좀
상승세가 가파르지 않은 모습
보여줬는데요.이는 미국이 어제 새벽
후르무주에서 이란의 성공격 영향을
전향한 추가 공습과 해성 봉쇄를
제기했고 공사 군사 행동이
이어졌음에도 유가는 좀 큰 폭으로
상승하지 않았고요. 시장이 주목한
것은 예고했던 20% 통행료 부가
방침을 철하고이를 걸프 국가들의
대규모 대미 무역 투자 계약으로
대치하기로 했다는 점을 좀 주목한 거
같습니다. 만약 20% 통행가
부과됐다면 원유를 포함한 모든 화물의
온통 비용이 올랐을 텐데이 방침이
철해되면서 그 부담이 좀 사라졌고요.
그 결과 군사 행동은 오히려 좀
강화됐음에도 유가는 2.1% 상승에
묻혀서 좀 충격이 크지 않게 나타나지
나타난 것으로 보입니다. 다음으로
중간에 위치한 52주 신고가
직구하였습니다. 어제는 아 어제는
뱅크오브 아메리카 모건 스탠리 골드만
삭스 JP 모건 MNT 뱅크 등
금융주가 명단을 사실상 거의 다
채웠고요. 그 기술주 중에서는
포티넥넷과 크라우드 스트라이크가
이름을 올렸습니다. 이날 발표된 은행
실적이 그대로 좀 반영된 결과로
보이고요. 특히 골드만스는 9%
급등하며 신고가를 세로 썼습니다.
그리고 다음으로 좌측 빅테크 및 주요
종목 보시겠습니다. 엔비디아가
4.1% 상승하는 모습 보였고요.
구글이 2.0% 오른판면
마이크로소프트는 1.5 5% 하락하는
등 대형 기술주는 좀 종목별로
엇갈리는 모습 보여줬습니다. 그리고
전일 급락했던 반도체는 SK
하이닉스의 ADR 27% 상승함과
동시에 마이크론과 램리서치가 4.9%
상승하였고 인텔 인텔이 4.5%
그리고 어플라이드 매트리스가 3.5%
AMD가 2.6% 올라주는 모습
보였고요. 오늘 샌디스크도 어제
전일자로 좀 많이 빠진 모습
보여줬는데 오늘 5% 상승 채로
마감했습니다.
SK 하이닉스 ADR에 대해서 좀
다뤄볼 예정인데 월요일 본주 급락분을
미국 시장에서 하루만에 좀 되돌린
모습 보여줬었고요. 상승의 직접적인
재료로는 바클레이스의 커버리지 계시로
보고 있습니다. 바클레이스는
커버리지를 한국 본주에서 ADR로
옮기면서 비중 확대 의견과 목표 주가
330달러를 제시했는데 전일 종가
대비 117%의 상승 여력이
해당합니다. 자, 핵심 근거로는 기행
공급 부족으로 2027년 비트 공급이
20% 늘어나는데 그치고 35%로
가속되는 수요를이가 따라가지 못해서
수년간 공급 부족이 이어진다는
전망입니다. 여기에 HBM 점률
50% 이상 유지와 2027년 말까지
시가총에게 40%가 넘는 현금이 쌓일
예정이고이를 대규모 자사주 매입
여력이 생긴다는 주조 환원 논리로 예
주장했습니다. 그래서 다만 본주와
가격 길이가 커지고 있는 모습 보이고
있는데요. ADR이 본주 대비 얼마나
비싸게 거래되는지를 나타내는 개리율이
상장 첫날인 지난 금요일
14.7%였는데
월요일에 24.7%로 좀 확대됐고요.
그리고 어제자로 48.8%까지이
8%까지이 개리율이 확대됐습니다.
그래서 어제 한국 분주가 3.7% 좀
상승해서 그친 반면 ADR 27%
급등한 결과인데요. 상상장 초기 유통
물량이 좀 제한된 ADR에 미국
수요가 몰리며 생긴 현상으로 보이고
그 같은 회사 주식이 두 시장에서
50%나 차이나는 게를 보이며 어
그이 거래되는 상태가 좀 유지되기는
어려운만큼이 계율이 어떤 방식으로
좁혀질지 좀 주시할 필요가 있어
뿐입니다.
다음으로 어닝 시즌 개막을 아닌
대원은행 실적 정리해 드리겠습니다.
공통된 특징으로는
변동성 장세 속에서 그 트레이딩,
특히 주식 트레이딩이 실적으로 좀
끌어올린 모습 보였습니다. 골드만
싹스는 주식 트레이딩 매출이 74억
달러로 예상치 50억 달러를 크게 옷
돌았고 자체 기록도 경신했습니다.
오늘 투자액 매출도 전년 대비 55%
증가하였고요. 그리고 JP 모건은
사상 최대 분기 이익을 기록했는데
주식 트레이딩이 예상을 20억 달러
이상 오픈되다. 장기 보유해 온 비자
지분에서 46억 달러의 이익이
더해졌습니다.
그리고 연간 순위자익 가이던스도
1030억 달러에서 155억 달러로
상향했습니다.
또한 뱅크 오후 오브 아메리카도 주식
트레이딩이 분기 기준 기록을 세웠고
시티 그룹도 예상치로 웃는 모습
보여줬습니다. 다만 시티는 주식
트레이딩이 기록적 수준이었음에도 그
성장세가 경쟁상에 못 미쳤다는 평가를
받고 좀 주가에서 약한 모습
보였고요. 그리고 다음으로 오늘 밤
일정 말씀드리겠습니다. 6월 PPI가
발표되는데 CPI에 이어 PPI까지
안정되는 모습이 확인되면 7월 동결
기대가 좀 한층 굳어질 것으로
보입니다. 그리고 목요일에 TSMC
상세 실정 나오는 거 전에도
말씀드렸지만 마진과 선분기 가이던스에
초점을 맞출 필요가 있어 봅니다.
그래서 오늘 내용 정리해 드리면 어제
시장이 6년 만에 하락한 CPI가
7월 인상 오료를 좀 걷어내고 통행료
철례로 유가 충격도 완화된 가운데
은행 실적이 어닝 시즌 출발을 좀
견주하게 열 하루였습니다. 그래서
그리고 SK 하이닉스가 바클레이스의
강한 매수 의견에 ADR이 좀
급등하는 모습 보였고 본주어의
게리율이 48.8%까지 벌어진만큼
오늘이 개리율이 어떻게 좁혀질지
지켜볼 필요가 있겠습니다.
이상입니다. 감사합니다. 위에 보여
주시는 표 보니까 유가도 금 유가는
어 79.8불 8불 소폭 좀 더
올랐고 금리가 아마 CPI가 예상보다
좀 낮게 나오면서 조금 하향된게
[목을 가다듬음] 아닌가 생각이 들고
그렇지만 여전히 지금 4.5%를
상회하고 있기 때문에 어 좀 충분히
내려와야 4% 가까이 좀 내려와야
시장이 특히 이제 중소형주가 급반딩이
나오지 않을까 하는데 아직 그
수준까지는 좀 한참 멀은 거
같습니다. 보여 주시는 표 보니까 어
TSMC ADR을 빼고 하이닉스
ADR을 넣으신 거 같아요. 그래서
왼편에
>> 빅테크 아래 반도체 부분에 보시면
앞으로 계속 하이닉스 ADR의 가격을
트래킹해 주실 것 같습니다. 가격이
[콧방귀] 50% 정도 이렇게 벌어진
상태에서는 어 실질적으로 롱숏을
하는데 있어서 제도적인 어려움이나 뭐
시차 이런 것들이 있겠으나 그럼에도
불구하고 이걸 또 이용하려는 그런
움직임들이 있을 거예요. 그래서
어디에선가 아마 이렇게 합의점이 좀
찾을 텐데 어 TSMC 같은 경우는
본주랑 미국 ADR이랑 한 10몇 %
정도 예 그 정도 괴리가 있죠.
그래서 어 일단 거기를 기준점으로
삼고 어느 쪽이 이제 붙던지 좀 붙지
않을까 하는 어 1차원적인 예상을
우선 좀 해 봅니다. 아마 가격
급등락 한국의 그 본주 가격
급등락에도
영향을 미쳐서 변동성은 당분간
하이닉스 주가가 좀 높게 유지되지
않을까 하는 생각도 좀 해 봅니다.
알겠습니다. 2부에서 좀 더 최부
사장님과 함께 자세히 알아보도록 하고
가상자산으로 넘어가 보겠습니다.
추약주인님 부탁드립니다.
>> 네. 상상 시장 말씀드리겠습니다.
어, 제 가격 흐름 보시면 아시겠지만
가격은 굉장히 좋은 좋습니다. 지금
65만 5,불까지도 돌파를 하고 있는
상황인데요. 어, 어쨌든 비트코인
가격이 최근 흐름상으로는 굉장히 많이
안 좋았지만 지난주부터 해서 이번 주
회기를 잘 기록하고 있다라고 보면 될
거 같고 결정적으로는 어제 CPI
별표가 어, 위험산 시장에 어,
가격을 좀 끌어 올리는데 가장 크게
기여를 했다라고 생각을 합니다. 어,
근데 어제 같은 경우에 SK닉스의
ADR만 강하게 올라오긴 했지만 디램
ETF랑 원래 비트코인 ETF를 일단
비교 놓고 봤을 때 디커플링이 굉장히
심했었거든요. 근데 그 디커플링이
조금 어, 완화되는 분위기로 어제는
흘러갔습니다. 어제는 어 그렇게
그렇기 때문에 이게 디커플링에 대한
요소보다는 CPI의 호재로 받아들이는
그런 부분들이 좀 더 크지 않았나 한
생각을 하고 어 마이크로스트리티지가
예를 들어서 그 말씀 어제 말씀드렸던
것처럼 그런 악재들을 해소를 시켜
줬으면 어 이런 저항 구간을 거치지
않고 바로 그냥 좀 돌파했을 거라
하는 그런 기대감이 있었는데 그런
[콧방귀] 부분이 아직 어 잔존하는
어 악지로 남아 있다라는 점은 어
분명히 조금 불안한 부분은 있는 거
같다라고 말씀드릴 수 있을 것
같습니다. 어, 오른쪽에는 비트코인
저항 구간이라고 제 써놓 차트를
보시면 아시겠지만 제가이 65, 한
400불 정도이 정도가 저한
구간이다라고 말씀을 드렸었는데이 정도
구간을 거의 피렌칭 같이 어, 지금
7월 한 달 거의 내내 어, 도전을
해 주고 있습니다. 그래서 지금 거의
다섯 번째, 여섯 번째 지금 도전을
해 주고 있는데요. 65,400불
정도를 넘으면 어, 추제적으로 좀
기술적으로 전환될 수 있는
구간이다.이 정도만 그냥 아시면 될
거 같습니다. 비트코인 엔그레드
인덱스 보시면 어 극단적 공포 구간에
있습니다. 22 정도를 기록하고
있고요. 어 그래서 제가 이렇게 좋은
흐름이 조금 그래도 그나마 이어지고
있다라는 점에서 비트코인 현물
ETF를 어제 한번까 봤더니 어 다시
한번만 유출세로 전환되는 어
월요일이었습니다. 그래서 421년
정도가 월요일에 유치가 유출이 되면서
흐름 자체는 조금 더 지켜봐야
되겠지만 어 유입세가 그렇게 어
지속이 되지 못했다라는 흐름으로
보시면 될 거 같고요. 어 아까도
청민 프로가 그 자세하게 설명해
주셨지만 CPI 별표 이후에 위험
자산이 슈팅이 나왔습니다. 그래서
에너지 가격이 [목을 가다듬음]
중점적으로 CPI가 좀 많이
빠졌고요. 그리고 코어피아도 좀
빠지게 되면서 어 굉장히 긍정적인
흐름으로 받아들인 거 같습니다. 어제
워시가 뭐 그 반기 어 통화 정책
이런 것들을 발표하게 되면서 여러
가지 코멘트를 해 줬는데 그중에서
조금 어 가장자 시장에 좀 대입
대입해 볼 만 했던 거는 가장자
시장이 지금 어 굉장히 흐름이 안
좋은 상황 속에 결과적으로는 흐름이
굉장히 안 좋은 상황 속에 속하고
있는데 어 우리는 베일하웃 할 생각이
없다. 그러니까 뭔가 그제 구명으로서
어떤 사업 부분을 살려줄 생각이
없다. 이게 뭔가 크립토만 말하는 건
아니겠지만 뭔 굉장히 어려움을 겪고
있는 섹터들을 어 정부의 돈으로 그럼
행정부의 돈으로 뭔가 구제 금융시켜
줄 생각은 없다라고 발언해 주면서 좀
선을 긋는 모습을 보셨다 이렇게
보시면 될 것 같습니다. 이건 사실
지난번에 배센트가 이렇게
언급했다라고도 똑같이 말씀드렸었는데
어 동일하게 행정부와 어 트럼프
행정부와 트럼프 재무부 이런 것들은
그 이런 행정 부처에서는 지금
크립토를 어 행정적으로 살릴 생각은
없다. 이렇게
어 오른쪽에 보시면 제가 블룸복의
차트를 가져왔는데 어 파란색이
IBIT 그 비트코인 차트이고요. 어
흰색선이 어 디램 그 ETF입니다.
어 이게 뭐 디램 뭐 IBIT가 더
높은 가격에 거래된다 이런 거라고
보시기보다는 그냥이 흐름 자체를
보시면 될 거 같은데요. 어 차트
흐름을 보시면 이게 디커플링이 어 한
5월 달부터 조금 지속이 됐었습니다.
그래서 5월 달에 조금 어 그때 한번
그 데드 크로스가 나오고 나서부터는
비트코인 가격이 계속해서 안 좋은
흐름으로 가고 있었는데 어제 같은
경우는 CPI로 같이 한번 같이
반등하는 모습을 보여줬었고요. 어
비트코인 낮은 상태에서 D램은 높은
상태에서 그냥 자체가 어쨌든 위험
자산 그리고 자금 유동성에 대한
부분으로 조금 민감하게 반응을 하고
있지 않나이 정도로 흐름을 보면 될
거 같습니다. 그래서 IBIT에
들어오는 어 수급 그 순 유입으로
들어오는 물량이라 가장자산 그 아 그
그 D램 ETF에 들어오는 순 유입
그 양량은 무조건 거기 디커플링이
일어나고 있습니다. 그러니까 디램 쪽
반도체 쪽에 어 수급이 훨씬 더
몰리고 있는 건 사실이지만이 ETF
가격 자체의 반응으로 봤을 때는 어
디커플링이 엄청나게 심하게 일어나고
있지는 않다라고 말씀을 드릴 수가
있을 것 같습니다. G슈는 간단하게
하나를 말씀드리면 될 거 같은데요.
어 제목 채굴자들의 물량도 소화 중인
시장이다라고 접성을 해 놨습니다. 어
초천은 포스라고 하는 온체인 어
데이터 어를 퍼블리시해 주는 데서
가져왔고요. 지금 가산자산 시장은
다양한 채널에서 매도세가 이어지고
있음에도 불구하고 그 충격을 잘
나눠서 흡수 중에 있습니다. 그래서
미국 정부로 추정되는 의심이 되는
지갑도 어 최근 비트코인을 조금
이동을 시켰거든요. 그래서 이게
이동을 시켜서 팔 수 있는 채널로
온게 온다라고 하는 건 이제 매도세
매도 압력이 조금 강해진다라고 해석을
하면 될 거 같은데 미국 정부도
그렇고 스트레티지도 그렇고 그리고
대부분의 채굴 기업들은 지금 AI
데이터 센터로의 시프트를 어 피보자를
하고 있기 때문에 다양한 채널에서
자금 조달을 위해서 또는 사업 부문의
전환을 위해서 비트코인을 매도를 하고
있는 상황입니다. 그래서 지금
비트코인 가격이 굉장히 좋았다라고
하면 이런 것들이 그냥 악재로
받아들이지 않고 무시되고 같겠지만 어
지금 하락장에 있는 상황 속에서 이런
것도 좀 민감하게 반응이 될 수가
있는데요. 어 역사적으로도 매도세가
악재가 해소되면서 그냥 어 가격이
슈팅이 나왔던 적도 있고 그냥
매도세가 악재로 그냥 받아들여지면서
어 가격이 좀 떨어졌던 적도
있습니다. 그래서 최근에
클린스파크라고 하는 어 채굴
기업이이이 기업은 한 17,000개
정도 비트코인 가지고 있는
기업인데요. 어, 자기 갖고 있는
것들이 한 10%에 가까운 물량을
시장에 던졌습니다. 그래서 지금 매도
압력이 이어지고 있고 아까 말씀드린
것처럼 스트레티지가 잔존하고 있는 그
한 3빌리언 정도의 비트코인 매도를
예고를 했기 때문에 그런 것들 다
악제로 남아 있는 상황이다. 이렇게
보시면 될 거 같고요. 어, 두 번째
여기 차트를 먼저 보시면이
매도 압력이 크게 크게 나올 때마다
가장 밑에 있는 그 빨간색 선이
이렇게 스파크가 쓸 때마다 매도
압력이 강하게 올라온다라고 하는 건데
어, 차트를 보셔서도 아시겠지만 이게
아까 말씀드린 것처럼 어, 매도
압력을 또는 통 동안 악재로
받아들여줄 때가 있고 그 상승으로
받아들여질 때가 있는 거 같습니다.
근데 어찌 됐든간에 이번 사이클,
그러니까 이번 하락장 사이클 25년
10월에이어서
이번 10월부터 지금까지로 봤을 때
역사적으로 두 번째 큰 매도 압력이
지금 이번에 나왔다 보니까 가격
흐름이 이번 CPI 호재 이후에
어떻게 반응하는지를 저희가 좀 보면
될 거 같고요. 그래서 아까 말씀드린
것처럼 어 이번에도 말씀드렸고
지난주에도 한 번씩 말씀을 드렸지만
온체인 데이터 그러니까 실제로 어
수급이 지금 유동성이 어 비트코인
시장이나 가장자 시장으로 들어오고
있는지에 대해서는 아니다라고 어 나온
여러 가지 데이터들이 있었습니다.
그래서 이런 상황 속에서 이렇게 어
물량을 소호하는 이런 과정들이 어
순조롭게 잘 이루어지는지 아니면 아까
말씀드린 것처럼 기술적인 것도 잘
반응하지 못하고 이런 매도 압력에도
악제로 받아들이면서 다시 한번
흘러내리는지는 저희가 좀 지켜보면 될
것 같습니다. 그러면 다시 한번 어
반도체적으로 유동성이 좀 쏠리는
모습이 보이지 않을까 어 그런
흐름으로 말씀드릴 수 있을 것
같습니다. 이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다. 우리 [콧방귀]
가상자산과 반도체는
어 일단 반도체 ETF는 실적 있는
기업들의 집합이다라는
관점에서 요거 두 개를 좀 같은
방향으로 가냐 다른 방향을 가냐를
보는 것이
>> 어 어떤 의미가 있을까 하는
>> 조금 더 근본적인 어 질문을 하게
되는데 어떻게 이해하면 될까요? 어
그냥 ETF 수급적으로를 좀 비교를
우선 간단하게 해 보고 싶었는데요.
어 결국에 이제 ETF에서
유출이 돼 가지고 그 돈이 어디로
갔을까 또는 어 한 ETF에서
유출세가 지속된다라고 하면 그 ET
돈이 어디로 갈까? 네. 네. 그걸
조금 비교를 좀 결정적으로 해보고
싶었는데 그거를 좀 가격적으로만 단순
비교하면 조금 어렵지만 어쨌든 그냥
가격적으로 원래 디커플링 5월 달에
좀 일어났었거든요. 근데 수급상으로도
아 수급상으로 봤을 때는 그
디커플링이 어떻게 될지 좀 지켜보긴
해야 되지만 유동성이 가장자산에서
나오는 ETF들이 대부분 반호체로
원래 쏠려서 갔었습니다. 그래서 그런
흐름에서 수급상으로가 좀 더 메인의
이슈다라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
정권을했을
때 그 유동성이 어갈 수 있을지를 저
예상을 해보면 될 거 같은데
>> 어 그게 가장 자산일지는 확실치 않고
좀 시켜봐야 될 것 같다가 결혼인 것
같습니다.
>> 이해했습니다.
>> 네.
>> 네. 네. 제슬리 모닝프 1부
여기까지 하고요. 잠시 후뷰에서
뵙도록 하겠습니다. 일부 함께 해
주신 최물 여러분 감사드립니다.
입니다.
안녕하세요. 행복한 투제 예정은
체슬리 투자 전문과 함께 체슬리
모니버리프 7월 15일 수요일 2분서
시작하도록 하겠습니다.
저는 어제 제일 먼저 확인한게
CPI였는데
야
>> 3.8 정도까지 떨어질 수 있다.
>> 그렇게 하셨는데 3.5 나와서 깜짝
놀하세요.
>> 그러면서 어
>> 급반등하겠구나.
>> 예.
>> 음. 그런 생각도 좀 들었는데.
>> 자 CPI 먼저 한번 볼까요?
>> 예. 그렇습니다. 어 예상했던
거보다 조금 더 낮게 나왔는데요. 어
예상이 말씀하신 대로 3.8이었는데
3.5%가 나왔고요. 어 전월
4.2%
나왔었기 때문에 어 전년 동월 대비로
보면은 5월이 확실하게 CPI
기준으로는 픽아웃하는 모습을
보여주면서
시장의 온기를 앞으로넣어줬고요.
[콧방귀] 특히 그 밑에 보시면 이제
에너지 쪽 보면은 5월 대비 6월이
월간 기준으로 5.7%가 하락을
했습니다. 그리고 밑에 세부 항목들
보시면은 뭐 9%씩 하락한 항목들도
어 보이고요. 어 그래서 그 부분이
전반적으로
그 CPI 하락에 어 긍정적 영향을
미쳤을 거라고 생각을 하고 있고 근원
CPI 같은 경우도 2.8%를 예상을
했는데 2.6%로
컨센서스보다 더 낮게 나왔습니다.
그 근원 CPI 중에서 가장 많은
부분을 차지하고 있는 어 쉘터 부분을
보면은 어 월별로 봤을 때 3 4 5
6 해서 어 0.3 0.6 0.3인데
6월에 0.1%가 1%가
나왔습니다.이 부분도 상당히 어
CPI가 낮아지는데 어 기어를 했던
거 같습니다. 그래서
전반적으로 어제 그 시장 금리도
10년물 기준으로 하락을 했고
패드와치에서 보는 동결 가능성도
올라갔는데
일주일 전에 동결 가능성이
65.8%였다면 8%였다면 어제
CPI가 발표된 이후 동결 가능성은
83.4%로 %로 어 올라갔습니다.
그래서 더욱더음
이전에 그 했던 금리에 대한 우려를
조금 불식시키는
이벤트였던 거 같고요. 밑에 CPI
관점 포인트 좀 보시면 어
JP모건에서 나온 그 CPI의
항목별 기어도를 보시면
지난번에 반복해서 좀 말씀드렸던 거
같은데 에너지 부분이 1.5% 5%
이상을 어 기여를 하고 있기 때문에이
에너지 가격이 하락하면서 헤드라인
CPI도 점차 이전 수준까지 어
내려갈 걸로 어 예상이 되고 있고요.
일부 어 치플레이션이라고 해 가지고
반도체 가격이 올라가면서 그 부분이
어 소비자 제품까지 전의되는 것들을
생각을 하는데 골드만삭스의
그 의견에 따르면 그 부분이
11월 정도에 나타날 걸로 어 예상을
하고 있기 때문에 아직까지는 좀 그
부분까지
예상하기는 좀 어렵겠지만음
0점
3% 포인트 정도 어 예상을 하고
있는 거 같더라고요. 그래서 좀
그분은 여전히 좀 봐야 될 거
같고요. 아 지금 어 오늘 어제 나온
CPI 쪽에서는 에너지 기어도 에너지
가격 하락의 기어가 컸다. 이렇게
보시면 될 거 같고 CPI 중에서 어
물가 쪽이 월별로도 떨어져고 있지만
전년 동월 대비로도 5월에 주거
물가가 3.4%에서 3.3%로
6월에 해양 안정되는 그런 모습들이
관찰됐습니다.
7월 30일 날 발표 예정인 헤드라인
6월 PC가 나오는데 그리고 근원
PC도 나오는데 아 블룸버그 쪽에선
아직 추정치가 그 직게가 되진 않고
있는데 아 클리블랜드 연운에서는
6월 PC 추정치를 3.65%로
보고 있습니다. 그래서 5월에
4.1% 대비해서 0.45% 45%
포인트 어 하락할 것으로 어 예상을
하고 있고요. 아 근원 PC 추정치는
3.3%로
5월에 3.4% 대비해서 0.1%
1% 포인트 하락할 걸로 어 보고
있습니다. 그래서
블룸버그 추정치는 아직 직계가 되지
않았지만 어 클리블랜드 연원에서
비교적 그 정확하게
추정을 해 왔기 때문에요 추정치를
믿는다면은
그 PC 발표도 그렇게 뭐 우려할
일은 아니다라고
보는 편이 합리적일 것 같습니다.
그리고 어제 은행주 실적들도 어 꽤
잘 나왔습니다. 은행주 중에 이제
신고가 찍는 그런 어 주식들도 좀
나오고 있는데 어 JP모건하고 어
골드만 싹스 오늘 좀 말씀드리면 어
JP모건 쪽에서 전반적으로 좀
무난하게 나오면서 어 2.5% 정도
상승을 했고요. 어 매출이 58빌년
나왔는데 YY로 27%가 아 증가를
했습니다. 순위자 이익이 9.9%
9%가 어 전년 동기 대비 올랐고요.
순위자마지는 한 2.4% 정도
나왔습니다. B자 이익 쪽에서 좀
일회성 비슷한 것들이 좀 있었는데
B이자 [콧방귀] 이익이 어 전년
동기 대비 44.9%
증가한 32.4빌리언 4빌리언 달러가
나왔는데 어 비자를 가지고 있었는데
비자 지원을 2008년 당시에 클래스
B로 가지고 있었는데 이때 거래가
지금 거래가 안 되는 상황인데이
클래스 B 주식을 클래스 C 주식으로
바꾸면서
지금까지는 원가로 평가됐던 것이 시가
평가되면서 그 차이가 평가 이익으로
반영됐다고 합니다. 그 평가 이익
자체가 4.6빌리언으로
꽤 많이 반영되면서 그 부분이 비이자
이익을 높이는 역할을 했습니다.
그리고 대선당금 같은 경우 어
컨센서스 2.62 빌리언 달러
예상했는데 어 2.52 빌리언 달러가
나오면서 어 컨셉보다 좀 낮게
나왔고요. 그래서 자산 건전성
측면에서도 크게 이슈가 없는 것으로
나왔습니다. 순익 같은 경우 YY로
41.2%
증가한 21.2빌
달러인데
앞에 나온 비자 평가액 한
4.6빌리언을
어 제거하고 보면은 한 2, 30%
정도 보시면 될 것 같습니다. EPS
부분도 YY로 47% 증간
7.7달러로 7달러로 어 나왔고요.
역시 일회성 부분을 어 제거하면은 한
30% 정도 어 증가한 걸로 보시면
될 [목을 가다듬음] 것 같습니다.
어 연간 가이던스로 순위자 이익에
대한 가이던스를 줬는데 어 컨센서스가
103.5빌리언 달러인데
105.5빌리언
달러로 어 소폭 상향 조정했습니다.
CEO 코멘트 보시면은 어 전 사업
부분이 사상 최대 매출을 기록했다고
했고요. 미국 경제에 대해서도
코멘트를 했는데 기업 투자하고 고용
중심으로 어 견조하지만 지정학적
긴장과 전쟁 그리고 끈적한 인플레이션
대규모 재정적 높은 자산 가격 등
리스크가 수면 아래에서 움찌고 있다.
제이다임은 회장은 항상 이렇게 좀
좋은 면과 나쁜 면을 보시키면서 좀
보수적으로 말하는 특징이 있기 때문에
어 그냥 참고만 하시면 될 거
같고요. Q&A 쪽에서
보시면 좀 특이할 만한 사항들을 몇
개 적어 왔는데 AI로 인해서 비용
증가가 둔화되고 수익성이 개선되는
시점이 언제쯤 되는지에 대해서 질문을
했는데 이게 조금 더디게 나타나고
있다는 얘기들이 나오고 있는데 어
JP모 같은 경우도 27년에서
28년쯤에나
비용 증가가 둔화될 가능성이 있다고
생각한다라고
어 코멘트했고요.
AI로 인해서 인력의 40% 감축이
은행에도 가능하다고 생각하는지에
대해서 물어봤는데 어 특정 부서에서
이미 30에서 40% 감축 후에
대부분 전환 배치 중에 있다고 얘기를
하고 있습니다. 아 최근에 산업별로
그 고용을 보면은 IT하고 금융
쪽에서 특히 레이어오프가 좀 많이
나타나고 있는 건데 아 그것과 좀
일맥 상통하는 코멘트인 거 같고요.
주식 트레이딩 부분이 86%나
증가했는데 요인이 뭐냐라고 어 질문을
했고요. 어 대형 IPO 지수
리밸런싱 한국 주식 시장의 다이믹스
그리고 전반적인 I시아 시장의
호조등으로 인한 것이지만이 조합이
반복되긴 어려울 것이다. 그래서 어
2분기에 특히 어 아시아 시장, 한국
시장 그리고 대형 IPO 어 요런
부분들이 있어서 주식 트레이딩 부분에
슬쩍이 좋았다라고 얘기를 했습니다.
케펙스가 AI 왜 영역으로 확산되고
있는지에 대해서 어 물어봤는데 AI와
무관해 보이는 대출 성장도 있지만
데이터 센터가 배관공 전기공 수요를
만드는 식으로 AI 테마가 여기저기
침투해서 구분하는데 어려움이 있지만
미국 전체 케펙스가 연사 출년
정도인데 아 그중에서 AI케스는 작년
400빌리언 달러 올해 700빌리언
달러 그리고 내년에 1출년 년 달러로
전망한다라고 얘기를 했습니다.
계속해서 IB 쪽에서도이 케펙스
전망에 대한 어 얘의가 나오고 있는데
계속 상향되고 있는 그런 상황입니다.
토큰 비용 즉 AI 사용료를
언급했는데 그 배경이 뭐냐라고 질문을
했는데 하반기부터이 AI 비용이
증가할 것으로 예상되는데 AI를
활용해서 사기 탐지 리스크 분석 문서
독해 회의록 작성 마케팅 문난 생성
작업을 하고 있는데 직원 30만 명
규모의 회사가 모델을 호출해서 작업을
하면 호출권수가 기아급수적으로
늘어나고 있기 때문에 의미 있는 AI
비용
증가가 하반기부터 있을 것으로
예상한다라고 코멘트했습니다.
주가 및 EPS 어 지금 52조
신고가 어 분해 있고요. EPS 계속
상향 조정되는 상황입니다.
13.7배 1700에 거래되고 있는데
한때 한 1600까지 거래되고 있는데
그보다는 좀 낮은 수준에서 거래가
되고 있는 상황입니다.
골드만 싹스한 9% 상승해서
끝났는데요. 보시면 순매출이 어
Yi로 39% 증가한 20.3빌리언
3빌리언 달러입니다. 어 크게 두
가지 사업으로 나눠졌는데 글로벌 뱅킹
앤 마케스하고
앤 웨스 매니지먼트 이렇게 돼
있습니다. 그래서 글로벌 뱅킹 앤
마켓 쪽에서 YY로 53%가
증가했는데 인베스트먼트 뱅킹이나
FICC 에코티 이쪽에서 어 전부 다
양호한 실적을 발표를 했는데요. 그
밑에 보시면은 에큐티 언더라이딩이나
that 언더라이딩 쪽에 보면은 어
각각 985밀리언
그리고 어 103밀리 어 985밀리언
그리고 1빌리언 이렇게 어 기록을
했는데 Y로 각각 130% 75%씩
엄청 많이 증가를 했습니다. 그래서
주식 인수 쪽하고 채권 인수 쪽에
상당히 호조를 보인 2분기였다고
보시면 될 거 같고 어에 앤 웰스
매니지먼트 쪽에서는 어 y로 20%
정도 어 증가를 한 4.6빌리언을
기록을 했습니다. 대순상각비 같은
경우는 뭐 인베스트먼 뱅킹 쪽에
특화된 은행이기 때문에 102년
정도음
발생을 했고요. 어 컨센서스
171밀리언이었기 때문에 앞에서
말씀드린 JP 모건하고 마찬가지로
대선 쪽에 큰 이슈는 없는 걸로 어
보여집니다. 순위익 같은 경우는
78% 어 증가한 6.6빌리언 달러
기록했고요. 그리고 EPS 같은
경우는 어 92% 증가한
20.98달러를 8달러를 기록을
했습니다. 그래서 전반적으로
채권하고 인베스트먼트 뱅킹 쪽에
상당히 강세를 보였다. 시장의 높은
눈높이보다도 더 높은 어 실적을
기록하면서
어제 어 9% 상승을 했다고 보시면
될 거 같고요. 어닝 스코에서 경영진
코멘트를 보시면은 AI 투자 사이클이
인프라 에너지 어 데이터 센터로
확산되면서 어 자금 조달과 자본
시장의 기회를 창출하고 있다고 얘기를
했고요. 어 대체 투자 펀드 레이징이
분기 사상 최대를 기록했는데
59빌리언을 기록했는데 여기에서
프라이빗 크에 쪽이 31빌리언을
기록했다고 얘기를 하고 있습니다.
Q&A 쪽에서 어 주식 본문 급성장의
배경과 지속 가능성에 대해서 어
물어봤는데 여기서도 역시 아시아
시장에 대한 호조를 얘기를 했고요.
아시아 시장의 우호적 환경과 맞물린
결과로 특정 트레이드가 아닌 전 지역
전 상품에서 강세를 나타내고 있다고
했고 AI 케픽스 사이클의 상황에
대해서 질문했는데
골드맨스에서는 사이클의 초기 국면으로
어 파이낸싱 수요는 전 지역 전
산업에서 일어나고 있고 슈퍼사이클
국면이고 3년에서 5년 동안은 지속될
것으로 예상한다고 했습니다. 어,
지금 AI발 강세를 닷컴이나
2021년과 비교하면 어떠냐라고
물어봤는데 IPO 쪽에서
측면에서 어 얘기를 했는데 이번 분기
IPO 물량은 10년 평균 이하
수준으로 역사적 극단은 아니고 가속구
재조정 부호 어 재가 속이 통상적인
경로가 될 것이라고 얘기하면서
어 보통 그 법을 국면에서 어
나타나는 IPO
증가가 아 지금 현 상황에서는 뭐
그렇게 크게 나타나고 있지 않다
이렇게 얘기를 하고 있습니다.
이상입니다. 아 여기 주가하고 EPS
오면은 뭐 오늘
그 실적 발표로 인해서 EPS가 다시
재조정될 것으로 될 어 예상이 되고
있고요. 어 PER은 어 17.9배
어 최근 1년간 가장 높은 어 PR를
주가 상승에 이인해서 어 기록을 하고
있는 그런 상황입니다. 이상입니다.
>> 네.
자, 미국의 대표적인 나이
뭐 축구로 따지면 스페인하고 프랑스
>> 예.
>> 예. 스페인하고 프랑스 붙어 가지고
프 스페인이 이겼더라고.
>> 많은 축구인들은 프랑스를
아마 이번에 우성으로 많이 뽑았는데
그 축구로 따지면 골드만삭스,
JP모컨, [목을 가다듬음]
프랑스, 스페인
>> 예.
>> 예. 그런비라고 보시면 되는데이
실적 발표랑 주가 흐름이 중요한
이유가
지금 둘 다 신고가 난 거죠.
가가 신고가 난 거고.
어이 신고가의 의미가 어제 KBS에
열린 토론에서 이선역
두 달만에 지난번에 5월 달에 한번
가스폰 이번에 두 달 만에 다시
만나서 토론을 했었는데
5월 달에는 제가 좀 신중론을 얘기를
했었다면 어제 같은 경우에는 이제
9,300에서
지금 6,500 뭐 6,800제
>> 예 그렇었죠. [웃음] 6.800이면
이제 무서울게 없다는 거죠. 왜
무서울게 없냐면 어제 못 보신 분들을
위해서 말씀드리면
우리나라 지수가 어 30%
빠졌잖아요. 그죠? 30% 빠졌는데
여기서 더 빠질까 봐 겁나는 거잖아.
더 빠질 거 겁나는 건데 우리나라
그동안의 코스피의 역사를 보면
반토막이 나는 경우도 많았어요.
코스피가 반토막이 나는 경우도
많았는데 그 반토막이 날 때는 항상
미국의 리세션 기간에 반토막이
>> 그러면 1989년까지
어 100에서 그때 1 올라가는 그
강세장 속에서 1990년도에 1에서
500까지 빠지거든요. 그때
1990년에 미국에 리세션이
있었잖아요.
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 그리고 500 갔었던 그 주가가
나중에 다시 또 천 올라오는데
우리나라 IMF를 또 겪죠. IMF를
겪면서 우리가 IMF 겪었을 때
277까지 가기는 했었지만
버블벌 직전까지 우리가 또
1050까지 쭉 올라왔는데
그러고 나서 다컴버블 때
리세션이었잖아요. 그죠?
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 음. 그때 500까지 빠져요. 50%
빠지는 거는 미국의 리세션이 왔을 때
그런 하락장에서 50% 빠지는 거지.
그냥 우리가 50% 지수가 고점 대비
빠진 경우는 없어요.
>> 음. 그러면 그 91로 460까지
터지고 그러고 나서 940 갔다가
거기서 이제 500원전까지
언저리까지 그 리세션 기간 동안에
다시 내려오는데 그 500에서
2003년부터 2007년까지
2080까지 2080 2080 같던
지수가 2008년도에 890까지 빠진
거는 2008년에 미국에 금융이
오면서 그러면서 리세션이 왔었죠.
네. 그럴 때 이제 50% 이상이래
빠지는 건데. 그러고 나서
2009년부터 10년 11년 해
가지고 다시 올라오고 그다음에 뭐
2,600 갔다가 그런 와중에 코로나
때 일시적인 리셋을 놓았었죠. 그죠?
그렇습니다. 시적이 그때 이제
1400 정도까지 빠지고
>> 그때도 뭐 정확하게
- 50% 나진 않았어요. 코로나게
마이너스 35% 정도 SMP 100도
빠지고 했었는데이 지금 이번에 고점이
얼마였냐면 9,300이었잖아요.
>> 예 그렇습니다. 9,300이면 그래서
제가 하반기에 [콧방귀] 박스로 많이
빠지면 6,300이 나는 거죠. 많이
빠지면 근데 어제 장중에 6,500
>> 터치했었잖아요.
>> 예. 그래서 뭐 저희 그 1림 계좌
최근에 들어온 1임 계좌들 중에 현금
있는 거 그냥 이제 다 소진내도
된다는 거죠.
그 정도에요.
그래서 그 열린 토론에서도이
과열일 때는 좀 조심해야 된다는 그런
부분은 말씀드렸지만 지금은 뭐 거의
이제 밑으로 더 빠질게 없다는 거죠.
그래서 어제 그 미국 시장 그러면
이제 미국 시장이 중요한데 미국
시장이 만약에 리세션으로 가는
상황이면 우리가 여기서 추가적으로
하락하는 거 5천까지도 빠질 수
있다는 거죠. 미국이 리세션으로 가는
상황이 되면
>> 5천이 깨질 수도 있고 그러면 미국이
리세션으로 가는 상황은 어떻게 알 수
있느냐? 이비들의
주가 추위를 보면 돼요. 아비들의
주가 추위가 지금 신고가를 내는데
>> 절대 리세션으로 가는 상황도 아니고
>> 오히려 그동안에이
빅테크 기업들이 작년 10월 달이
고점친 이후로 꽤 많이 쉬었잖아요.
>> 예.
>> 예. 꽤 많이 쉬었고 그동안 이제
반도체 랠리 케펙스에 대한
[목을 가다듬음] 부담 프리 프리
캐시플로우가 나오지 않는 거 아니야?
뭐 이런 여러 가지 노이즈 속에
부당을 많이 좀 쉬었는데 오히려
반도체 부분의 노이저가 오히려
빅 빅테크 기업들이 약간 순통이
터지는 그런 부분이 나오면서 미국
시장은 보면 하나도 미국 시장은
걱정할게 없어 보인다. 그렇다면 다시
우리 시장에 지금 고점 대비이
30%에서는 어떻게 해야 되나요?
음. 이제는 뭐 그래서
어제 KBS에서 열린 토론도 딱
끝나고 나왔더니 오 동수가 최고
나왔다.
>> 예. 그게
그
일단은
우리 시장에 대한 부분에 있어서
우리가 어떻게 접근을 할 건가에
있어서 미국하고 뭐 중국도 보고
우리는 다 전체적으로 큰 그림을 보고
있잖아요. 이게 매크로하게 이렇게
쳐다보면 그 거기서 이제 딱 하나 어
마음에 걸리는게 이번에 아 CPI가
또 나쁘게 나오면 어떡하나 했는데 어
어제 딱 CPI 나온 거 보고 제가
>> 휴 이제
반등 한 최소 8,000원 향해 가는
>> 반등이
>> 또 시작됐다 그런 생각을 했었습니다.
그래서요 빅테크들의 실적이 되게
중요했고요. 여기 이제 Q&A에 보면
또 중요한 부분들이 하나 있어요.
저도 여기 지금 어 JP 모건만
하더라도 주식 트레이딩 부문이 86%
증가했는데 요인은 뭐냐 했는데 여기
생통막게 한국 주식 시장의 다이네믹스
>> 예 그렇습니다.
>> 이게 들어가 있어. 예. 직접
언급했습니다.
>> 예. 전반적인 아시아 시장 보조등으로
인한 것이지만
근데 또이 조업이 반복되기는
어려워요.이
>> 정도의 다이나믹 [목을 가다듬음]
>> 그래서 그동안에 한국 시장이 좋아서
분명히이 트레이딩 부분에서 수익에
기어를 했다이 말이잖아요.
>> 그렇습니다. 예.
>> 예. 근데 이런 기어가 계속
방법적으로 일어나기는 또 어려웠거든.
그런 얘기를
>> 그건 모르는 건데 모르는 거지
>> 보석으로 얘기한 거 같습니다.
>> 그래서 우리나라 시장의이
JP 모건 같은 모건 스탠이나 골드만
삭스 다 그 안에 이제 프라 트레이딩
부서가 있잖아요.
>> 자기
고유 자금으로 운용하는 그런 트레이딩
부서라든지 예 한국 시장 와서도
열심히 돈 벌어갔다는 얘기
>> 그렇습니다. 예.
그리고 밑에 골드만 석스도 비슷한
코멘트가 있더라고요. 보니까
>> 아시아 시지장 시장에 우호적 환경과
맞물린 결과로
>> 특정 트레이드가 아닌 전체역 전 상품
강세를 보였다. 어 이런 얘기가 있기
때문에
어 그래서 어 저도 이들의 실적이 또
어떻게 나오는가 그이 부분도 좀
궁금했는데 상당히 실적 좋게 나오고
어 정보파
>> 예 그렇습니다.
>> 예는 모습이 나와서
>> 우리 시장에 여러 가지로 긍정적인
직업 분위기가 이제 조성됐다. 이번에
신용도 좀 많이 틀렸고 틀린 분들은
>> 제가 어제 거저께도 그냥 이번에 이게
스스로도 이제 한번 써보고
>> 어 트레이딩 포드리빙이라는 그
알렉산더 엘더라는
>> 음
>> 어 헝 러시아 출신의 심리학자가 이제
미국 오셔 가지고 그 쓰신 책에 보면
제일 중요한 단어가 그런 얘기를
해놔요. 어 사람들은 내가 뭔가
엄청난 테크닉 내가 대단한 정보를
몰라서 돈을 잃는다라고 생각하는데
작용 관리가 안 돼서 돈을 잃는다라고
>> 그래서 머니 매니지먼트이 자금 관리가
제일 중요하다는 얘기를 딱
>> 예 맞습니다. 예, 저는 트레이딩
포드리빙 그 책을 보면서 굉장한
테크니컬한 예, 그런 걸 얘기해 줄
줄 알았는데 딱 그 부분을 얘기
그래서 이번에 좀 어, 작은 관리가
안 돼서 쉬워 가지고 어, 그런
아쉬움이 있는 분들은 그거는 한번
백서도 한번 써 보시라고 제가
>> 자, 조금 아쉬운 부분 중에 하나는
어, 심년물 국채 금리가
좀 확 빠졌으면 좋을 텐데 아직까지도
>> 4.59.
>> 예, 그렇습니다.
>> CPI 저 정도 나오면
>> 좀 4.3, 4.2까지 떨어져야 되는
거 아닙니다.
>> 네. 그런데 뭐 이미 지나간
데이터이기도 하고이
물론 이제 일부 반영한 거일 수도
있는데 지금 WTI가 시원하게 안
빠져 가지고 어 그런 부분이 있는 거
같습니다. 지금 79.8불인데
8불인데 이전 수준으로 가려면
60불대 후반 뭐요 정도까지 가야
되는데요 부분이 조금 어 팬딩돼 있다
보니까 그렇고 또 약간 미일한
노이즈가 최근에 좀 나오고 있어서
그런 부분들을 좀 의식한 거 아닌가
어 싶습니다.
>> 네. 그렇죠. 아까 아직까지는
진영학적인 어 문제가 언제든지 또
육가가 밀어힐 수 있는 거 아니냐는
불안감.
>> 예. 요런 것 때문에 대롱대록 매달려
있고 마지막으로요 아까 그 CPI
그림 있잖아요.
>> 예.
>> 그림 한번 다시 띄워 주시면
어 여기 어 CPI 인플레이션
기어도에서 저는 그런 생각이 드는
거예요. 지금 4.2까지 갔다가
3.5로
뚝 떨어졌잖아요. 그죠?
>> 네. 그전에 제일 앞단이 지금
제뉴얼이 18 해 가지고 2018년도
1월부터 나오는데
>> 요때 2018년도에 보면 한 7월
요때 언저리에 CPI가 3
찍었더라고요.
>> 예예.
>> 그때 미국의 CPI 아 그 10년물
국제 금리가 어 10월 달쯤 돼서요
3%를 10년물이 살짝
>> 음
>> 뚫거든요. 위로. 네. 그러면서
시장이 이제 화장창 무너졌었는데
어 요때 3%였을 때 미국의
10년물이 3%를 후적으로 따라갔다는
거죠.
>> 예. 예. 맞습니다.
>> 그러면 이번에 4.2까지 올라가면서
10년물이 야이 계속 올라가는 거냐
아니냐 하면서 종동발 위기도 있다
보니까 4.6까지 갔는데 3.5까지
뚝 떨어졌잖아요.
>> 예. 그렇습니다. 그러면 약간 시차는
있어도 10년물 국제 금리가
떨어지겠다.
>> 음.
>> 그래서 아까 어떤 분이 질문도 해
놓으셨지만이 10년물 국제 금리가
이제 언제 떨어지는가? 요게 이제
관건이거든. 요게 관건인데 어
2018년하고 지금 되게 비슷해요.
반도체 랠리도 비슷하고
>> 트럼프 대통령 2년 차인 것도
비슷하고
>> 그런 부분인데 어
여기서 CPI가 큰 폭을 이제 떨어져
줘서 어 다행이다는 생각이 들고
그리고 나중에 이제 10년물이 한
3개월 후행하면서 이제 좀기 때문에
>> 그 아까 말씀하셨던 이제 PC도 봐야
되거든요.
>> 예. 그렇습니다.
>> 네. 이거 저거 봤을 때
>> 어쨌든 어 저는 2018년하고 19년
조태 CPI가 어 저렇게 빠지고
CPI가 2%가 깨지잖아요. 19년
되면
>> 깨지고 그다음에 어 요때 당시에
10년물 국제금이가 3% 찍었던
10년물이 1.5까진가 빠졌을
겁니다. 19년도에
>> 네. 그러면서 SM 완전히 랠리가
예.
>> 예. 나왔었기 때문에
>> 제가 내년 시장을 되게 좋게 본다라고
말씀드리는 이유도 또 2018년에서
19년 넘어갔을 때에 CPI나 뭐
여러 가지 면이 다 좀 되게
비슷해요.
>> 비슷하기 때문에.
관건은 이제 금리에 있다. 금리는
또이 CPI이랑 이런 거에 달려
있다. 이렇게 좀 보시면 될 거죠.
자, 그러면 어 국내 시장으로 넘어가
보도록 하겠습니다.
네. 어제 [목을 가다듬음] 국내
시장 말씀드리겠습니다. 코스피 지수
0.7% 37% 오음새로 마감을
했고요. 코스닥은 약 2% 하락
마감했습니다. 어제 코스피 변동성도
굉장히 크게 나타났었고요. 뭐 장중에
45%까지
하락세를 보이다가 오후장에 반등에
성공을 하는 모습이었습니다.
수급적으로 보면 개인 추하자 4조대
매도가 나왔었고요. 반면에 외국인 한
1조원 정도 순매수가 있었고
기관에서는 3조 2천억 가량 매수세가
유입이 되기도 했습니다. 어 메인
선물에서 최근에 이거래일 동안
조단위의 매수세가 유입이 되고
있는데요. 전일장에서도 1조 6천억
대수세가 있었습니다.
투자자별 매매 동향으로 보면 외국인
투자자는 SK하이닉스 1조 3,억
매수했습니다. 외국인이 모처럼
하이닉스에 대한 매수를 좀 강하게
했던 모습이었고요. 그 외엔 SK
스퀘어, LG인노텍, 삼성전기, 어
테크윙, 삼성전자 우선주를 매수를
했고요. 메인 매도에는 삼성전자,
원익 IPS, 대덕 전자, 삼성
SDI, 이수페타, KB금융, 테스
등을 매도했습니다.
기간 매수에는 삼성전자 1조 3,억,
SKX익스 약 1조 3천억 매수하면서
두 종목 합산 한 2조 6,억 가량
매수를 했고요. 그 외에는 삼성전자
우선주, 대덕전자, 원익 IPS 등을
매수하는 모습이었습니다. 기간
매도에는 SK 스퀘어, LG노텍,
가운전선, 알테오젠 등을 매도를
했었고요. 52주 신고가 종목 총
다섯 개 있었는데 코스피에서
하나금융지주, 한성기업이 두 종목이
신고가의 이름을 올렸고 코스닥에서는
테스, TSE, 인피니티 헬스케어
어이 세 종목이 신고가였습니다.
특징적이었던 거 최근에 반도체나 뭐
IT 종목들 굉장히 약했었는데 테스나
TSA 같은 소부장 업체들이 신호가
이름을 올렸던 건 좀 특이한 점이었던
거 같습니다.
자 웬만한 종목들은 다
오르겠더라고요. 저는 신기한 차트
분석하면서 쭉 말씀드렸지만
>> 신차 분석에서도 제 CPI 보기 전에
뭐 종목별로이 쭉 다 보니까 웬만한
거지다. 다 다 올라가. 어제 이제
바이오도 좀 빠졌는데 그 그
CPI가 저렇게 나오면
섹터 종목들은 다 기술적 이제 반등이
들어가는 국면에 들어갈 거 같고요.
외국인이 간만에 이제 하이닉스도 많이
샀고
기관에서는 전자 하이닉스를 다
자 그러면 주요 종목들 동령네
>> 어제 반도체 섹터 봐 주시면 대형
반도체 쪽에 삼성전자가 3.3
SK니스가 3.7% 정도 상승을
마감했습니다. 아까 창민 프로가
아침에 언급을 해 줬었는데
SK이닉스와 ADR 간의 지금 주가
개이가 워낙 커졌기 때문에 갭을
메꾸는 어 기간이 좀 오지 않을까라는
생각이 좀 들고요. 아래 소부장
종목들 봐 주시면 한미 반도체가 어제
실적이 나왔습니다. 컨센을 비타하는
실적이 발표가 됐었는데요. 뭐 실적
따라 어제 움직이는 장 흐름은
아니었기 때문에 한 1% 정도
상승으로 마감했던 거 같고요. 어,
주성 엔지니어링이 한 5% 정도 워닝
IPS 1.8 상승했고 아래 기판
쪽에 대덕 전자가 한 3% 가량
오음새로 마감을 했습니다. 뭐 소부장
종목들은 대체로 좀 혼조세 느낌이 좀
더 강했던 거 같고요. 그래서
밸류에이션을 좀이 시에 좀 보면 좋을
거 같은데 30배 미만으로 내려온
선단 기업들이 좀 있습니다. HPSP
26배가 됐고요. 그리고
이오테크닉스는 31배 정도 수까지
내려왔는데 이오테크 한 45배 거의
50배까지 갔다가 30배 초반까지
떨어져 있고 리노 고이 26배
정도거든요. 그래서 리노나 HPSP
이런이 두 종목은 저는 항상 봐았지만
반도체 여항이 좀 괜찮을 때는 30배
미만에선 언제나 어 좋은
기회였었다라는 생각이 좀 듭니다.
나머지 종목들도 뭐 30배 미만으로
떨어진 선단 장비나 부분 쪽이 좀
보이고요. IT 섹터에서 전기가
2.2% 하락했습니다. 어 최근에 좀
주가 흐름이 많이 안 좋은데요. 거의
고점 대면 50% 정도 반토막 정도
났거든요, 지금.
>> 그래서 밸류에이션도 46배.
46배라고 보면 절대적인 숫자는 비싸
보이기는 하는데요. 향후 이익
추정치를 보면 이익이 내년에 거의
100% 늘어날 것으로 추정이 되고
있기 때문에 뭐 밸류가 그렇게
비싸다라고 보기는 좀 어렵다. 그래서
전기는 최근에 외국인들이 계속
매수세가 있었거든요. 그래서 아마
이번에 만약에 전자와 하이닉스가
반등을 좀 강하게 한다면 폐로 같이
올라갈 수 있는 종목이 아닌가는
생각이 듭니다. 플랫폼 섹터는 대체로
좀 2% 대에 하락하면서 부진한
흐름이었고요. 어제 니케이 지수
0.7% 7% 올랐습니다. IT
종목들이 그래도 반등이 조금씩 나오는
모습인데요. 무라타, 호야, 디스코,
어드반 테스트 등이 상승세를
보였습니다.
배터리 체인 쪽은
LG 엔솔, SDI, 뭐 에코프롬,
LNF, 셀리나 뭐 양극제 쪽 뭐
대체로 좀 크게 하락하는 모습이 양제
쪽 중심으로 좀 나왔던 거 같고요.
자동차 섹터에서는 현대 기아, 현대
모비스, 오토에버 등이 또 약세
흐름을 모였습니다. 좀 금리가
떨어졌기 때문에 현대차 쪽으로도 좀
매수세가 유입이 될 가능성이 있지
않을까라는 생각이 들고요. 소비제
섹터는 어제 좀 안 좋았습니다.
확실히 대형 반도체가 쉴 때, 하락할
때 좀 어느 정도 방어해 줬던 섹터
중에 하난데요. 어젯장에 반도체가
올라오다 보니 좀 약해지는
모습이었습니다. 내용화장품 쪽도
부진했었고 최근에 OEM ODM 쪽
많이 강했었는데
좀 코스맥스나 코스메크 코리아 낙폭이
좀 크게 나타났습니다. 피용 기기도
좀 안 좋았는데요. 클래시스 파마
휴젤 API 원택 다 약했습니다.데
어제 기사 보니까
미국 증시에서이 화장품 관련된
ETF가 상장이 된다고 하는데요.
국내 한국 K뷰티가 비중이 한 80%
정도 들어간다라고 하는데 제가 정확한
건 못 봤고 이제 헤드라인 정도만 본
거 같거든 좀 찾아보고 말씀드리도록
하겠습니다.
>> 음.
>> 네. 그리고 음식률 섹터는 3형시품
3.4 농심이 좀 약세였고요.
KTNG도 무진했습니다. 그리고
백화점 섹터도 최근에 하락이 좀 큰데
신세계가 5%, 현대 백화점 2.6
하락하면서 원먼스 기준으로는 좀
낙폭이 큰 상황이고요. 조선 철감미
기타 섹터 보면 조선주들 대체로 4%
정도의 하락세를 보이면서 좀 부진했던
거 같습니다.
그리고 아래 뭐 철광인나 화학 섹터도
마찬가지로 부진했고요. 엔터 아 그
방산주 쪽 봐 주시면 하나로 6.8
8 넥스원 8% 현대 로템 2.7%
하락하면서
방산주들의 흐름도 굉장히 험악했었던
하루였고요. 바이오섹터도 대체로
부진의 특히 코스닥 바이오에서
알테오젠이 10% 이상 빠지는 흐름이
나타났던 것 같습니다. 그리고 아래
증권이나 금융 쪽 안 좋았고요. 엔터
쪽은 어 하이브를 비롯해서 대체한
3% 약세 보였습니다. 그리고
반도체가 좀 반등하다 보니 변합기
섹터가 조금 올라오는 모습이
나타났습니다.
그렇죠. 뭐 ABL 바이오 이런 거는
연초 이후 62.8%
>> 하락입니다.
>> 스펙트론 57% 하락.
자, 주요 종목들 동량은 봤고요.
어, 삼성전기 좀 전에 얘기하셨었는데
이게 240만 원 넘었다가 지금
120만 원
>> 네. 거 반토막이 지금 나 있는데
>> 어 되게 좀 배터가 높다고 예 보면
좀 될 거 같고
삼성전기
엄민규
연구원의 자료인데 제목이 AI
사이클을 지탱하는 대장주다라고 돼
있습니다.
주가가 뭐 많이 급등한
변동성이 커진 것도 있는 거 같고요.
이게 과거에는 좀 성장주 개념보다는
약간 가치주 느낌이었잖아요. 약간
PBR로 평가하면서. 음.
>> 근데 성장성이 워낙 급격하게 붙다
보니 주가도 그에 맞춰서 명동성이
굉장히 크게 확대가 이번에 됐던 거
같고요. 제목을 보면 AI 사이클을
지탱하는 대장주라고 해서 지난주에
나왔던 리포트였습니다. MLCC 가격
인상도 아직 시작을 안 했다라고
하는데요. 2분기 예상 매출액은 3조
정도 전망이 되고요. 영업익 4,억
정도 추정을 했습니다. 영업 이익이
Y와Y로 90% 증가할 것으로 보고
있고요. 영업 이익 컨센이 약
3,800억인데이를
좀 상해하지 않을까라는 전망입니다.
최근 북미 CSP양 LTA 공시를
통해 CSP가 선재적으로 LTA를
제한할 정도로 수급이 좀 타이트한
상황이라고 하고요. AI 고객권는
일반 MLCC 대비 수배에서 수십배
높은 ASP도 충분히 수용이
가능하다라고 합니다. 매출 내에
고부가 AI 서버양 비중 예상보다 좀
빠르게 확대가 되고 있음을 확인을
했다라고 하고 구조적 쇼티지는
수요보다 공급이 부족할 때 발생을
하게 되는데 이번 LTA 업체외의
다른 CSP들도 보상 MLCC가
필요하지만 공급사는 삼성 전기와
무라타로 제한되어 있기 때문에 추가
수주 가능성도 매우 높은 상황이라고
합니다. 1분 계기 기준 MLCC
가동률은 95% 정도로
나왔고요. AI 서버용 MLCC는
일반 MLCC 대비 생상 능력을 재배
수준으로 소모한다라고 합니다. 회사는
MLCC 케펙스를 전년 대비 두 배
이상 확대하면서 20% 이상 케파
증서를 준비 중에 있지만
IT 제품 제고축적 수요까지 겹치면서
수급은 더욱더 타이트해지는 모습이
나타나고 있습니다. 어 제품
믹스에서만으로도 ASP는 지속적인
상승이 예상이 된다라고 하고요.
쇼티지에 따른 가격 인상은 아직
본격적으로 시작되지도 않은 단계라고
합니다. 어, 플리j도 얘기를
했는데요. 역시 본격적인 가격 인상
시작전이라고 합니다. 플리치 BJ
가동률은 2분기 기준 90% 초반까지
상승을 했고요. 하반기에는 풀캐파
정도 도달이 예상이 된다라고 합니다.
글로벌 CSP 및 AI 인프라
업체들과 신규 공급 계약을 논의 중에
있는 상황이고 2분기부터 하반기로
갈수록 대면적이나 고다층 쪽 서버용
기판 양산이 본격화될 것으로 추정을
했습니다. 그러면 애플리시 PJ
업체들이 일제 증서를 좀 진행
중이라고 하고요. 생산 과정의
케파로스와 어 수요공 증가 보의 공급
확대를 크게 좀 상여하는 상황이고
공급 부족 28년 이후에나 돼야
완화될 것으로 판단을 한다.
하반기부터는 쇼티지에 따른 판가
인상이 본격적으로 진행될 것으로
추정을 했습니다. 이비이 연초에
증설을 한다라고 이미 밝혀 놓은
상황이고요. 근데 기판이 한 2년
정도 증설이 걸리거든요. 좀 빠른
1년 반이긴 한데 어쨌든 공급이
늘어나려면 한 2년 정도 걸리는데이
쇼티지가
한 최소 1년에서 2년 정도는 이어질
가능성이 높다. 근데 아직 가격
인상은 시작도 안 됐다.라는 라는
이야기가 리포트에 주된 내용이었던 거
같고요.
아래 전기 실적 추정치를 봐 주시면
올해 예상 매출액이 13조
8,억입니다.
>> 그리고
영업 이익으로 내려가서 보면 올해
예상이 1조 7,300억 정도가
추정이 되어 있고요.
내년이 더 놀라운 거 같은데요. 내년
되면은 매출액이 18조 3천억 그리고
영업 이익이 3조 3천억입니다.
그래서 각 사업부별로 보면 컴포넌트
쪽에서 한 2조 정도의 매출을 올려
아 이익을 올려 줄 걸로 보고
있고요. 방학 솔루션은
어 1440억 그리고 패키지 솔루션
기판 쪽인데 여기도 한 1조 정도의
이익을
어 예상하고 있는 거 같습니다. 영업
이익률로 보면 내년이 한 18%
정도의 우피 마진 전사로 했을 때
나올 것으로 보고 있고요. 컴퍼넌트
쪽이 23%
패키지가 22% 정도 수준으로 추정을
하고 있는 상황입니다.데
컴퍼넌트 쪽이 마진이 더 잘 나올
수도 있을 것 같기는 합니다. MCC
가격이
올해 아직 올라가지도 않았는데 영업
이익률이
10% 중후반대가 나오고 있거든요.
그래서 가격이 올라가면
MLCC가 한 30% 40% 내년에
올라갈 수 있다라고 가정을 해 보면
영업 이익률이 이것보다는 더 높게
나올 가능성이 있다라고 개인적으로
생각은 하고 있고요. 오른쪽에 전기의
투자블 순매수 추위를 봐 주시면
메모리 반도체의 경우는이 가격을 올린
주체가 거의 개인 투자자들이었잖아요.
이번에이 급격한 상승을 만들어 낸
게. 근데 삼성전기는
외국인이 만들어냈다라고 볼 수가
있거든요. 외국인과 기관은 거의
순매수세가 작년부터 이어져 왔는데요.
개인들은 작년부터 계속해서 좀 팔아
왔던 흐름입니다.
수급 쪽으로는 오히려 메모리 쪽보단
좀 여유로운 상황이지 않나 생각이 좀
들고요. 아래는 제가 이제 전기
발표할 때마다 말씀드리는 그
자료인데요. 결국 MCC 가격이
어떻게 움직일 거냐를
그리는게 중요해 보이는데 1분기 때
5원이었습니다. 근데 가격 인상이
이제 시작되는게 올해 하반기 정도로
보고 있고요. 그리고 내년 되면은
한 2, 30% 정도 올라간다라고
가정을 해 보면 7원까지 MSC
가격을 확장해서 볼 수가 있겠다.
근데 이게 좀 합당하다라고 볼 수
있는 건 코로나 때
어 3원이었던게 한 5원까지
갔었거든. 음. 근데 그보다 훨씬 더
고부가 제품이 지금 확장이 되고 있고
심지어 그때랑 또 다른 건 전동차
그니까 전기차 쪽으로에 대한 MCC도
이전보다 비중이 많이 높아진 상황이기
때문에 고부가 쪽으로 가고 있는데
고부가는 올라가면 더 많이 올라갈
가능성이 있잖아요. 그런 부분을
가정하면
7원을 넘어서 뭐 8원까지도 바라보는
것도
이상하지 않다라는 생각이 들 듭니다.
그러면 28년의
영업 이익은 한 얼마 나오는 거
지금?
>> 음. 27년 추정치는 3조에서 3조
3천 요렇게 나오는데 이게 올해
하반기부터 이제 내년 초까지 매매를
하려면 어 28년 이익을 보면서 어
해야 되거든.
>> 네. 그렇죠. 근데 3조인데 이번에
150조 갔으니까 3 155 해
가지고 내년 실적 다 당겨도 영업
이익 그걸 기준에서를 50배가 되는데
그러면서 주가는 내년 이익은 풀리
반영을 하면서이 올라간 거잖아요.
>> 네. 그죠. 이번에 그랬다가
뭐 150쪽까지 갔다가 너무 이제
멀티플이 과하다 보니까 조정받을 때
그냥 한 방에 반토막 나 버렸는데
자이 지금이 가격에서는
어 한 25배 정도니까
사 볼 만한 이제 가격이 됐거든
>> 가격이 됐는데
>> 여기서 사 가지고 트레이딩을 할 거냐
아니면 어
후년 28년에 만약에 이제 8불까지
올라가면 그럼 이익 추정치가 어
내후년 되면 이거 뭐 6조
나옵니다.음 음 6조 나오면 뭐
120조 가도 20배밖에 안 되니까
내운년을 좀 해야 되는데 일단
MLCC 가격 추위가 만약에 ASP가
이렇게 된다면 뭐 3조
3,000원보다는 더 많이 나겠네요.
그
>> 28년 추정치가 있어요.
제가 추정한 그 MLCC만 제가
추정을 한번 해 봤었는데요. 기쪽은
아직 안 해봤는데
>> MCC로 제가 7.5원을 기준으로
그니까 계단 가격을 7.5원 5원
기준으로 했을 때 가동률 95% 정도
돌아간다라고 보면 한 2조 3,
4천억 정도는 MLCC 쪽에서 나올
것으로 저는 추정을 했거든요.
>> 여기서 이제 조금 더 추가할 수 있는
건
>> 실리콘 캐패시터 쪽인데 그 부분은
아직 영원님들 추청치에 본격적으로
반영을 안 하고 있다고 하더라고요.
그 부분이 이제 첫 수주기도 하고
>> 음
>> 어 그 데이터 센터형으로 첫
수주거든요. 그래서 그런 부분을
반영을 해 보면 그게 한 영업 이익률
20% 중후반이 나올 수 있다라고
시장에서선 얘기가 나오는데 그것까지
감안해 보면 MCC 쪽에서 한 2조
6천억에서 2조 7천억 정도를
[콧방귀] 기대해 볼 수 있다는
생각이 들거든요. 그래서 그런 부분
감안해 보면 저는 그래도 한 4조
정도는 전사해서 4조 정도 나올 수
있지 않을까 그런 생각을 듭니다.
28년도에
>> 네.
어 위원님들 중에서 가장 추정시가
높은 위원님들이 6.5조에서 7조
정도 보고 있거든요.
>> 28년화.
>> 네. 그렇게 하면은 이제 순위
기준으로 한 5.5조에서 6조원 정도
가량이기 때문에 어 지금 시가 총액
100조원 기준으로 한다라고 보면은
한 18배 정도의 PER 28년도
기준으로 위치하고 있다라고 보시면 될
거 같고 여기서 관건은 아까도 그
과장님 말씀해 주셨던 것처럼 실리콘
캐파시티인데 뭐 MLCC나 아니면
기판 같은 업체들은 기판 같은
사업부들은 삼성 전기가 직접 생산을
해서 그리고 납품을 하는 구조인
거잖아요. 근데 실리콘 캐시터는
전기가 제작을 하진 않거든요. 그
파운더리처럼 이제 외주를 맡기게
되는데 그렇기 때문에 영업 비용률이
사실 어느 정도 높게 나올지 전혀
지금 예상이 안 되고 있고 많게
보시는 분들 같은 경우에 30%까지도
보고 계시는 거 같더라고요. 그래서
>> 어 뭐 닉스나 이런 쪽들이랑 좀 다른
거는 어 큐하고 영업 이익률이 내
훈년까지도 급하게 같이 달려
올라간다라는 점인 거 같습니다.
그래서 피해 관점으로 보면은 굉장히
저렴한 거 같습니다.
>> 네. 오케이.
>> [목을 가다듬음]
>> 28년에 대한 이익에 대한 컨ඟ션이
있어야 어 이번에 한번 반토막이 나는
걸 경험을 했기 때문에 어 올라갈 때
또 자신있게 이제 들고 갈 수 있을
쓸 수가 있기 때문에 한번 말씀을
질문을 한번 해 봤고요. 어 여기
지금 MSC 가격 추임및 전망요
그래프만 보면 우리가 이런 생각을 할
수 있어요. 어 그때도 코로나 때도
거의 뭐 6불 건처가더니 또 가격이
확 밀려버렸었잖아요. 그죠? 이게
이렇게 되면 어떡하나 뭐 이런 생각을
할 수가 있는데 예 그때는 코로나
구제금으로
발생한 노트북이라든지
여러 가지 IT 기기에 대한
일시적인다면
앞으로는 뭐 전기차를 비롯해서 뭐
앞단위에서 뭐 요봇 등등 엄청
열린다는 거지.
>> 네. 저는 근데 되게 뭐
[목을 가다듬음] 의미깊게 봤던
자료가 일반 그 서버 쪽으로 나가는
MLCC 대비해서 그 AI 가속기
쪽으로 나가는 MLCC 있잖아요.
>> 어 똑같은 용량을 탑재한다라고
하더라도 거의 10배 증가를
하더라고요. 그래서 어 매물이랑 좀
매물리 대비해서 PR를 되게 세게
받을 수도 있다라고 생각을 하는게 어
우과장님 말씀해 주셨던 것처럼 P
상승은 확실히 메모리보다 더디긴
하거든요. 근데 Q가 어 폭발적으로
증가한다라는 점에서 뭐 생각보다도
피해를 많이 줄 수도 있겠다라고 좀
생각을 했습니다.
>> 그게 중요한 [목을 가다듬음] 제네.
이게 케파가 좀 해 보이긴 하거든요.
이게 지금 단기적으로 늘어날 수는
없는 거 같아서
>> 저는 그래서 28년에 연구인들이
숫자를 굉장히 높게 찍어 놓긴 했는데
>> 음
>> 저는 그거는 조금
>> 보로 봐야 될 수 있겠다. 왜냐?
MC 증설은 하는데 그게 그렇게
단기적으로 빨리 끝나는게 아니고
>> 음.
>> 예를 들어 올해 28년에 뭐 완공된다
해도 가동률 올라오는데도 시간이
걸리고 하는데
>> 6 7조 찍으려면
>> 그 그냥 온기 반영 실적을 다
반영하는 것 같은 느낌이 있거든요.
>> 당장 목숫자에 대한 컨백션 자체는
저는 좀기는 합니다.
>> 음.
그러니까 [웃음]
어
그 선구 얘기도 맞고 우석기 얘기도
맞고 예 저는 이제 정리가 확실하게
됐어요.이 반도체가이
빅크로스가 사실은 그렇게 큰 건는
아니거든 그죠.
거기에 비해서 이제 P 증가율이
높아왔었고 근데 요쪽 MLCC 쪽은
어 P도긴 하지만 이제 Q가
폭발적으로 늘어나는게 이제 반도체랑
좀 다른 점이다.
>> 그 부분이 중요한 포인트인 거 같고.
하지만 그 Q가 폭발적으로 늘어나는
거 앞단에서 Q가 폭발적으로 늘어나는
거 맞는데이 공급단에서는
페파 정설은 뭐 그렇게 뭐
하겠다라는데도 아직까지는 그 정도
증설 얘기를 하지는 않았고 한다고
하더라도 가동이나 이런 거 다
감안하면 그 앞단의 폭발적인 수요
증가만큼 큐를 공급하지는 못할 거다.
그래서 결론적으로는 어 그러면 내년
내후년까지 쇼티지는 계속 되겠네이
생각이 들었어요. 지금 제가이 최근에
3년 동안에 주식 시장에 가장 중요한
키워드는 쇼티지라 했잖아요.
그렇다면음
대충 정리가 되는 거죠.
그 중에 중간중간에이
주가만 너무 좀 과하다 싶으면
조정받고 또 어느 정도 매력적인
가격대가 되면 또
하방이 지지가 되겠구나.
>> 네.
>> 예. 그렇게 결론이 있습니다. 자,
그다음에 어 반도체 얘긴데 제목이
반도체는 잘못이 없다. 고양입니다.
>> 누가 잘 뭐가 잘못인가? [웃음]
일단 리포트
>> 하수 시장에서 이제 가금을 많이 받다
보니까 좀 이런 제목을
>> 쓰신 거 같고요.
>> 네.
단기 급격한 주가 조정 이후 7월
투자 전략에 대해 우리가 좀 점검을
해 보자라는 이야기데 지난 4월
터보컨트에이어서 업종 내용이 최근
주가 조정의 이유라고 보기 어려운
20년 두 번째 반도체는 잘못이 없다
구간으로 보고 있는데요. 근본
조정으로 최근 부담이었던 수급 솔린도
많이 해소가 됐다라고 볼 수가 있겠고
7월 중 나온 저점 레벨을 깨지 않을
바닥으로 설정할 필요가 있겠다. 아마
7월까지 이어질 매크롬이 빅테크
케펙스 확인 심리가 남아 있기 때문에
단기 박스권 전개 가능성을
존재한다라고 보고 있고요. 빅테크
실정및 국내 메모리 대형주 실적 발표
추세적 랠리 제게 될 것으로 보고
있고 23년 이후 매년 7월부터
나타나는 우려의 시선이라고 하는데요.
AI 수요가 만든 반도체 사이클는
23년 4월부터 시작을 했는데 이후
현재까지 이어져오고 있는 과정에서
공통적으로 발생하고 있는 현상이
있다라고 합니다. 3반기 업종 주가가
상승했을 때 하반기 AI 투자에 대한
우려가 확대가 되었다라는 것이고요.
그러나 실제 펀더멘탈 영향은 매번
제한적이었다라고 합니다. 최근 메타
이슈를 시작으로 빅테크 실적
발표에서의 케펙스 관련 우려감이
형성이 됐었는데 이에 대해 오히려
하드웨어 프리미엄의 시작이라고 본인은
판단을 한다고 합니다. 에이전트나
피지컬 AI로 전개되는 과정에서
위크들의 플랫폼 사업자 지위는 축소될
것으로 보고 있고요.이를 이를 유발한
것은 M비디아의 소프트웨 오픈소스
전략이라고 볼 수가 있겠는데 세포
시대와 달리 에이전트 시대부터는
빅테크의 플랫폼 관점이 아닌 생태계
전반의 서비스 경쟁이 시작될 것으로
본다. 오히려 테크의 역할은 CSP
즉 클라우드 사업자로서 집중될
것이다는 전망을 했습니다. 앞서
말씀드린 그 7월부터 나타나는 우려의
시선이라고 하잖아요. 그래서 제가
SK닉스의 차트를 월봉으로 켜서 좀
봤는데
>> 7월 달에 확실히 안 좋더라고요.
13 이후로 음
>> 그래서 상반기에 좀 많이 올라가게
되면 이제 반기 동안 먹은 그거에
대한 뭐 차익 실현 뭐 그리고 또
리밸런싱 수요도 좀 있을 거고 대체로
그 전년도의 그 상 다음의 실적을
미리 추정을 할 때 좀 대체로 높게
추정을 많이 해놓잖아요. 그 그
부분들이
>> 상반기에 만년 반영돼서 주가를
당겼다가
>> 하반기 시작할 때 좀 차익실한 욕구가
많이 나오는 상황에 또 악제들이 또
그때 좀 많이 나왔었다라고 볼 수가
있을 것 같고요. 그다음 변화목이
좋은 업항이라고 해서 올라올 곳
정확기 트리거는 실적 컨콜이라고
하는데요. 아직 끝나자는 추정치
상향이라고 합니다. 3분기나 4분기
그리고 27년까지 컨센서스의 추가
상향 상향이 유력하다라고 하는데요.
향후 상향을 유도할 중요기 및 4분기
27년까지 ASP가 완만하게
둔화될지에 대한 부분을 확인해야
된다라고 하고 각사가 목표한 LTA
구조는 증가율이 둔화되더라도 완만하게
전개되도록 현재 설계가 되고 있다라고
합니다. 7월 29일 SK닉스 7월
30날 삼성전자 컴을 통해 관련
힌트가 확인이 될 것으로 보고
있고요. 투자 전략 쪽으로 넘어가면
공고하게 주될 낙동강 방어선이라고
합니다. 7월 둘째 주까지 형성된
주가 저점은 깨지지 않을 바닥으로
공고하게 유지될 것으로 전망을
했고요. 하단을 단단하게 지지해 줄
업항이 7월말로 갈수록 확인될 수가
있기 때문이다. 하단 근처로 갈수록
두려움보다는 용기를 좀 내야 된다라고
하고 7월 말 재료 확인 이후 8월
추세 랠리 재개를 기대하면서
삼성전자나 하이닉스
VM에 대한 적극 비중 확대 의견을
유지를 했습니다. 아래 차트로
내려가서 보면 SK이닉스의 23년
주가 추위 그리고 24년 주가
추위인데요. 확실히 상반기의 강세를
보였었고 7월을 기점으로 한 두 달
정도 23년에 쳤다가 이제 좀
올라가는 모습이 다시 좀 나타났는데
어쨌든이 표소도 알 수 있다시피
상반기만큼의 그런 폭발적인 상승세가
하반기에는 좀 나오지 않았었다. 어느
정도 박스권에 좀 위치했던 모습인 거
같고요. 저희 하우스도 이제 올해에는
전자나 하이닉스가 정글점을 뚫기보다는
좀 박스 어느 정도 반등하고 박스권에
좀 횡보하는 구간으로 가지 않을까라고
생각을 하고 있는데 그와 좀 비슷한
어 차트 모양이 과거에도 있었다라고
볼 수 있을 것 같고요. 그다음
24년인데요. 이때도 상반기에 굉장히
주가가 강했었고 그다음에 아마 모건
스탠리 리포트가 이때 윈터스 윈터
룸스인가 나왔었던 거 같은데 그
이후로 이제 주가가 어 많이 빠졌었고
박스권에 빠진 다음에 좀 박스권에
갇치는 모습이 나타났었던 거
같습니다. 그리고 오른쪽에는 25년
주가 추인인데요. 이때는 상반기에도
올랐었고 하반기에도 좀 많이 강했었던
모습이긴 한데 어쨌든 보면은 7월
달, 7, 8월 달 정도는 좀
상승세가 둔화되는 모습이 확실히 좀
관찰이 됐었던 거 같고요. 그다음
26년 주가 취인데요. 이번에 상반기
때 너무나 좀 강했었는데 하반기
들어와서 7월 달 6월 달부터 사실
주가는 조금 둔화되기 시작했고 7월
달에 이제 큰 낙폭을 시현을 했는데
여기서 어느 정도 또 반등이 나오고
박스권에 갇칠지 아니면 25년도처럼
어느 정도의 조정 좀 거친 나에 바로
또 이제 올라가는 모습으로 또
단기적으로 갈지는
어 이번 달 말에 있을 미국 테크
기업들 실적 발표나 하이닉스 실적 적
전자의 확정실적 발표가 트리고가 되지
않을까 싶습니다.
음.
우리 문상모님은요네
가지 케이스를 보면서
어 앞으로 어떻게 될 것 같습니까?
주가 흐름 주의가
>> 일단 장기적으로는 이제 가격 상승에
대한음 기대감들이 반영되면서 주가
상승 압력을 좀 같고 그 후에는
구차적으로 이제 가격에 대한 이제
저항 대회적인 그 노이즈 체크를 할
것 같아요.
>> 음.
>> 그 이후에는 내년 Q 물량 얼마 안
할 수 있을지 이런 거에 대해서
체크가 이러실 것 같습니다.
>> 음.
자, 여기 어네 가지 주가 추의가
있는데 어 그 앞에 다른 년도도 좀
같이 보면 좋긴 하겠지만요
23년 같은 경우에는 반도체가 계속
역성장하고 하이닉스 적잖을 그렇죠.
네.
>> 음. 삼성전자가 4조 4천억인가 6조
4조 4천억 영업 이익 나고 하이닉스
7조 접자 났을 때음 이미 22년도에
그렇게 안 좋을 걸 선반영하면서
22년도에 주가가 박살 났을 거고
그죠에는
오히려 24년이 좋을 걸 선반영을
하면서 쭉 올라와 왔었고 그러다가
24년도에요
5번 스탠드에서 반도체 겨울었다. 다
뭐 요런 얘기 때문에
7월 달에 한번 빠졌다고 반등이
들어가는데 거기서 그 리포트가
나오면서 다시 한번 빠지는 모습이
나왔었고 그러고 나서 그 리포트
나왔을 때 수준까지 다시
돌아왔어요.요
두 번째 지금 차트 24년 보시면
되는데 반등이 들어오고 그리고 다시
빠졌던게
제고가 너무 많다.
>> 네.
>> 그때 그죠. 재고가 뭐 50조다.
그런 얘기 나오면서이
전자 같은 경우에 좀 험악하게 빠지고
하이닉스 같은 경우에는 그나마 HBM
때문에 어 버티면서 왔다 갔다 하는이
>> 모멘텀이 계속 우상향하고 있었기
때문에 그 리포트에도 불구하고
빠졌다가 예 반등이 [목을 가다듬음]
들어갔다가 재고이기 때문에 저러다가
그러고 나서 25년 차를 보면
이런저런 노이즈 뭐 사실 재고가 많긴
많았었잖아요 그때 네.
>> 그래서 뭐 낸더도 왕창 적자였고
당시에 23년하고
어 24년
넘으면서 23년에는
영업 이익률이 -80이었을걸 아까
그렇죠. 파는 좋죠.
>> 예. 랜드 쪽은 100%
넘어갔습니다. 마이너스 마이너스
100% 넘어갔었고 [웃음]
그랬다가 25년 이제 하반기부터이
본격적으로
메모리 가격이랑 랜드 가격이
시작하면서 25년도에 저렇게 올라왔고
지금 26년이 요런 모섭인데
2018년도로
들어가더라도 2018년도에 5월에
고점 찍고 왔다 갔다 하다가 하반기에
좀 무너졌어.
그런 트라우마도 있고 뭐 2019년
20년 뭐 2019년에는 미중 무역
분제 갈등 때문에 아까 미국 시장
좋았다 했는데 우리 시장은 2019년
8월 달에 트럼프 대통령의 또 중국
폭탄 관세 그러면서 2019년 8월에
오히려 우리 시장은 저점
그런 식으로 아무튼 더울 때 아 더울
때는 제가
7 89 아예 안 하는게 나올 수도
있다는
그 정도로이 789가이 특히나 짝수의
789가 어려운 구간인데
어쨌든 이제 맞았어요. 예. 조정을
가격 조정은 충분히 이제 다
이루어졌기 때문에 앞으로 이제 어떤
식으로 주가 움직임이 전개될까 어
부분인데 일단은 24년
그림년하고는
조금 다르기 때문에 예 23년은
완전히 이제 바닥 치고 24년
턴라운드
시작하기 딱 직전의 모습이었기 때문에
어 23년 모습보다는
24년 년 저만큼 이제 그 뭐
그 만들면 손실 이런 재고가 막 제고
평가 손이 나는 그런 국면은 아니기
때문에
>> 약간요 박스인데 약간 우상향 박스
우상 박스는
앞으로 3개월 정도 그러지 않을까?
근데 종목의 주가 움직임 뭐 그건 뭐
알 수 없어요.
>> 자, 그 미장에서
어 한국 ETF가 5.36 올랐고
야간 선물도 5% 이상 올랐고
하이닉스가 급등을 했기 때문에 오늘
삼성전자 하이닉스에 대한 주가가
시조가가 굉장히 강하게 좀 반영을
하지 않았을까 싶은데
시장은 어떻게 시장이 됐습니까?
>> 네. 시장은 3.3% 어 상승에서
출발을 했었고요. 현재는 5.9%까지
어 상승폭 확대를 하고 있습니다.
>> 7,261포인트입니다.
>> 네. 코스닥은 어떻습니까?
>> 네. 코스닥 2.77%로 상승
출발했고요. 현재 3.81%로 어
상승 또 조금 확대하고 있습니다.
>> 네. 어제 하락 때문에 아침에도 아마
어 장 시작할 때 반대 매매가 좀
나왔을 거는 그래서이 야간
선물이라든지 오늘 시장은 어 상당히
좀 강할 것 같은 거에 대한 느낌보다
시장이 약하게 시작한 거는 반대
매매가 아마 시초가 좀 나왔을 거고
어 오늘 같은 시장은 어떻게 될지는
조금 있다가
오늘 전방 듣고
자, 어제 미국 시장은
SP 500 그다음에 나스닥 빠진다고
했나요? 빠진다고 했나요? 어떻게
됐죠? 전망이 좀 빠질 거 같아요.
>> 둘 빠진다 빠진다.
>> 네. 둘 다 빠졌다.
>> 올랐는데.
>> 네.
>> 어.
오늘 밤에는 어떻게 될 거 같아요?
음.
SP 500부터 한번 해 볼까요?
거꾸로 맞추는 것도 좋아. 계속
거꾸로 맞추면
>> 거꾸로 대응하면 되니까
>> 뭔가 오늘 오 거 같은데 유가 유가가
벌써 더 좋
>> 유가가 어떻다고?
>> 유가가 WTI가 80% 근접하고
있어서
>> 아, 지금? 네.
>> 음.
>> 그래서 어떻?
이거는 그렇지만 상승 외치도록
하겠습니다.
>> 상승
>> 네
>> 나스닥은 어떻게 될 거 같아요?
파락하겠
>> 하락
>> 어 어제이어서 오늘도 하락 전만
>> 네
>> 역시 스승님이 제일 낫네
>> 보니까 예측률로 보니까
>> 어 세사장은 거의 다 맞추고 있는데
보니까
어제는 그저께는 빠질 것 같다
얘기했고
>> 어제는 어젯밤 시간 오를 것 같다
>> 얘기했고
>> 오늘은
오늘 모를 것 같습니다. 오늘 오후
한 3시쯤에 우리시고 3시쯤이나
4시쯤 그 사이에 ASM에 실적
발표가 있어요. 유럽 쪽인데
>> 예 유럽 쪽인데
>> 제가 볼 때는
전망이나 코멘트 이런 것들이 나쁘지
않을 것 같거든요. 왜냐면 어 최근에
앱에 대한 그
어 그 건설 맵 건설 관련된 그 어
규모 자체가 굉장히 확대가 되고
있어요. 그래서 아마도
실적보다는 어 향후의이
그 대체로 뭐 내년 내운년을 바라볼
때 굉장히 좋을 거라고 분명히 나올
것 같아요. 그래서 장비주
관련된 반도체 주식들이 어 모멘텀이
나쁘지 않을 것 같습니다. 그래서
내일은 그 오늘 밤 그 열리는
시장에서는 아마 ASML과 더불어서
어플라이드 머티리얼이나 램 리서치,
KL, 테라다인 이쪽이 좀 모멘텀이
강하지 않을까 그런 생각이 듭니다.
>> 그리고 요즘 유럽 시장이 나쁘지가
않아요.
>> 나쁘지 않습니다. 유럽 시장
견정합니다.
>> 그 예.
그렇다면 지금과 같은 분위기에서 뭐
나쁜 반응을 보일 것 같지 않고 어제
>> 아비들의 주가가 신고가를 보 있는죠.
>> 그런 부분들이
>> 조금은음
투자 심리가 현재는 나쁘지 않 보이기
때문에 자 상승 전환으로 아 상승
전환이 아니라 오늘도 상승 피는
그렇게 전망을 해 주셨습니다. 네.
자, 우리 시장 어 코스닥은 어제도
음봉 얘기했었죠.
>> 오늘은 어떻게 될까?
>> 오늘도 음봉입니다.
>> 오늘도
>> 네.
>> 오늘은 양봉 좀 가자. 나는
양봉할게. [웃음]
>> 뭐 시스템
아니 정말 많이 못다이가 그렇지.이
정도면
시스템은 근데 냉정하게 해야 돼.
실대로
안 돼.
>> 나는 연공했어.
시스템을 눌러야 되겠어.
코스피는 어떻게 됩니까?
어제 딱 그 말씀드렸던 120일선을
딱지지 뭐 깨고 내려가긴 했었지만
>> 음고
>> 다시 깨고 너무 많이 내려가길래 전
아 이거 이번 시장 완전 끝난 건가?
점심 먹으면서 입맛이 싹 떨어졌는데
>> 네. 그래도 올라오는 모습에 좀
다행이라는 생각을 많이 했던 거
같고요. 그래도장은
점심은 먹었나 봐.
[웃음]
어제 같은 상황에 밥이 들어가.
난 어제 점심 안 먹었어.
>> 어제 맛있는 거 먹었어. 대찌개.
>> 어 아픈 대찌개 이맛 없을 때도 짠게
당기서
>> 그러니까 아 비올 때 대치개 너무
맛있지. 예. 그럴 때 좀 나한테 좀
어 같이 가자고 얘기 좀 하. 제가
[웃음]
>> 한번 장 안 좋을 때 한번
>> 성구랑 먹었나?
>> 성구랑 왕부장
>> 좀 얘기 좀 해 줘. 왕부장. 어
우리는 뭐 좀 그렇다 하더라 왕부장은
그래도 어 내 팬 아니가 왕부장
[웃음]
>> 아 나는 왕부장 내고 그지. 그렇죠.
>> 어.
아, 그래서 오늘은
저는 좀 밤에 CPI 무서웠거든요.
그거 만약에 잘못 나와 가지고 빠지면
이번에 120선 어제 한번 깼기
때문에지지 못하고 한꺼번에 데려가
쏟아질 가능성이 있어서 좀 무서웠는데
어쨌든 그것도 잘 나와서 또
이제 오늘은 양봉 가능성이 좀 더
높은 안도렐리가 좀게 아닐까라는
생각.
>> 음.
다행이요. 그죠? 그 그게이 파생도
반대 매매가 있거든.
>> 네.
>> 파생도 반대 매매가 있어서 그리고
스닥론도 있어요. 신용만 있는게
아니라 스닥론 있어요. 음.
그래서이 반대 매매 나오는게 9시에
나오는 경우도 있고 10시 반도 있고
뭐 11시 12시 그 대충 이제 반대
매매가 마무리되는게 12시더라고.
>> 음. 음.
>> 그래서 어떨 때는 제가 살려면
12시에 살 뭐 이런 얘기를 가끔씩
하잖아요. 보면
>> 그게 어제 딱 시장에서 그런 모습이
나왔었어.
>> 다행히 어제 같은 경우에 그래도
밑꼬리 달고.
>> 그리고 어제 신차 분석에서도
얘기했지만 어제 매도한 사람이 다시
못 사게 만들어요. 이게 찐바닥이면
그죠. 어제 두려움에 바닥에서 이제
판 사람들이 어 뭐야 내가 잘못
팔았네 다시 살려면
>> 그 그래서 시장이 되게 냉정한데
그러면 다시 못 사게 만들려면 갭으로
시작해져야 돼 갭 시작해 가지고 어
밑으로
어제 가격을 안 만들어 준다는 거죠.
그런 면에서 나는 코스닥 양뽕이라고.
[웃음]
>> 근데 아 너무 그동안에 진짜 너무
험악하게 봤어. 그죠?
>> 어제 개인들 4천 4조 1천억
팔았잖아요.
>> 아 그거 처음 보너었잖 거 같아.
그러니까 빠지면 보통 사고 올라가면
이제 팔고 잘 하셨는데
>> 이번에 뒤늦게
>> 주식을 좀 뒤늦게 이렇게 들어오신
분들
>> 그다음에 종목으로 내가 터진 거 두
배짜리도 그냥 만해하겠다.
거기다가 두 배짜리를 만해하는데
신용까지 쓰면 근데 두 배짜리가
신용이 되나
배네.
>> 아무튼 신용이 38조 언저리였다고
그죠?
>> 예.
그 신용이 이제 안 되면
>> 어쨌든 저봤는데 홍콩 쪽으로
털렸어요.
>> 홍콩 쪽 콩 레버리지 레버 두
개짜리죠.네
>> 어제는 하나시 좀 보니까 아침에 9시
반에 개인 매도 나오잖아요.
>> 10시 반은 홍시장 열래요. 그래
10시 반 그때 매도라도 한 번에
나왔어.
아마 연관선 있지 않을까 싶어요.
>> 음. 아 홍콩 시장에서도 반대 매매가
>> 10시 반에요.네
>> 10시 반 시장. 그다음 우리나라
시장하고 시차가시 차니까
>> 네. 한국 시간 10시 반니다.
>> 아 한국 시장 10시 반
>> 그 영령도 있었겠다. 있을 것 같아.
감사합니다.
자 아까 어떤 분이 어제 어저께
샀다면 그러면 이거는 어떻게 해야
되냐? 뭐 이거는네 개 써 놓으셨는데
그게 이번에 매를 심하게 맞았잖아요.
- 30%면 심하게 이제 맞은 거기
때문에
>> 그렇다면 여기서는 조금 그래도 그
중간값이
한 7, 한 800 정도
되거든요.값이
>> 1700원짜리
그 정도 뭐 피 포인트까지는
올라간다고 봐야 되지 않나?
>> 네. 그런 생각 하기 때문에 너무
바닥에서 또 조금 먹고 팔면 어
하면서 또 올라가는 경우
그 중심을 좀 잘 잡고 매매를 하시면
좋고
예 어제 동접자수가 와 2,200이
나왔을 때 어 이러면 바닥인데 옛날
때 정확하게 바닥쳤어요.
>> 그러니까요. 어
체슬리 모닝프 모닝브리프 동적자수
새로운 인덱스가 나타했습니다.
>> 오늘도 아까 실시간으로 또 2,명
왔었는데
>> 음
>> 예 좀 그동안에 어이 변동생에 많이
마음 고생하셨을 건데 이것도 시장의
일부다. 어 이런 비성적인 시장
짜증나서 못 해 먹겠다. 나 다시
미장 갈래 이러신 분도 계고 안
됩니다. 예. 내 마음을 다스려
그죠.
>> 예. 미장도 만만치 않습니다.
[웃음]
>> 그러게.
>> 이장도
>> 어 미장은 뭐 쉬운장이야.이
뭐 최부 사장님 입장에서는 그죠?
예. [웃음]
>> 쉽지 않습니다.
>> 하긴 어제 IBM 20% 이상
빠졌죠.
>> 그러니까요.
>> 뭐죠?가
>> 없습니다.
>> 그러니까 미정이 신인 줄 알고
>> 가봤더니 안 올라가고 그 M7 같은
것도 안 올라가고죠.
M7만 사면 그냥 다 해결되는 줄
알아주는
>> 사니까 별로 재미없고 빠지고 막
이러니까
>> 그러니까
>> 그런 분들 고민 많으신 거 같습니다.
나의 짜증과 반대 방향으로 하세요.네
[웃음]
채널의 모닝 브리퍼 오늘은 9월
17일 아 9월 17일 9시 17분을
[웃음] 보고
>> 네
>> 7월 15일 수요 전사는 여기까지
하겠습니다. 저희 최선님과 함께
복가고 슬비놈 투자 이어나가시길
바라겠습니다. 고맙습니다.